this is my first coffee of the day you
need some time to rev up the engines man
what you gonna do now don't talk to me
until i've had my coffee
you single-handedly like
exhausted house how supportive
all i want is one connor all i want is
one i'm on the one drinking like five
[ __ ] capsules a day
i wonder why we're through a coffee
shortage no i wonder why
we live in a society all right welcome
back to this episode of trash taste i'm
with the boys
what did you say
you know what guys
i'm i'm i'm i'm gonna quit
[Music]
i can get it quick
i got a new phone right and i saw the
comments like oh my god i got the pixel
six already i got it day one right
you're a fake fan kidding me so my my
last phone as some you guys know and i
have some sort of complaint about it i
had the pixel 4 before it was dying yeah
and i got this phone everyone's like how
is it connor it's good but it's also
really [ __ ]
why why there's so many annoying things
that like i don't know why like okay so
so okay you guys know me big fan of my
chromecast i think we're all aware i
love my chromecast yeah
sorry i think it's it's your most used
appliances
right so yeah exactly so i go to my bed
right and i'm like oh the volume is too
loud let me turn it down
okay okay normally i would just like
press the volume button on my phone when
it's being cached to the tv and it would
go down yeah it isn't doing it that's
weird okay maybe it's just like this it
was a one-off and then it doesn't happen
again it doesn't happen again turns out
uh yeah it's like an intended feature
they just removed it and then i was like
why and then apparently there was like
it's a legal issue i'm like it's a legal
issue for me to turn my volume up and
down what's going on what's going on
google is it to stop people at parties
from like turning the volume too high
maybe i i don't i don't think why would
that be a legal issue that's a that's a
dick friend issue you know i was like
has google been taking uh notes off
apple or something just like
guys guys this is an intended issue you
know what you're not i i think i'm still
like the the only person left in [ __ ]
2021 that makes that misses the [ __ ]
auxiliary no auxiliary [ __ ] bro
sometimes sometimes you need it
sometimes you [ __ ] need it sometimes
sometimes kids today will never get a
choice
god is the reason why we don't have
progress in humanity he holds on to the
artifacts of old i'm sorry that
sometimes you like you go in an old car
or something that doesn't have bluetooth
connectivity i'm sorry that not everyone
owns a [ __ ] tesla or something you
know
some some that makes its own music yeah
some people our age are still [ __ ]
broke and their radios or their [ __ ]
music play knees and knocks everything i
missed the day when i could say yo pass
me the orcs yeah yeah yeah i got honest
i can't say that [ __ ] anymore dude
i gotta be like you pass me the
bluetooth like my brother had the same
problem you know when his first car he
had the cassettes only that would go
into oh hell yeah so we had to get a
cassette to aux cable
and that was really cool though just
seeing how like how it worked i don't
know i don't understand that that's
gonna come back in a couple years time
it's gonna be cassette to bluetooth yeah
it's like a bluetooth cassette to pop in
this is the corporations selling us like
that they're like they're making an
issue and then they they're selling
they're selling us the solution
like have you seen the apple are now
like adding more ports
even though the people who remove the
ports are apple themselves so they're
just like apple
let me show you on this okay let's let's
create an issue ourselves track of the
scene
and then let's sell the solution to our
customers and frame it as a solution
that we didn't make in the first place
like what what genius it's true that's
true
i really hope that everything just goes
usbc as well i'm i'm just i want
everything to be the [ __ ] saying yeah
and thank god that yeah thank god europe
is like hey apple [ __ ] you
do usbc we don't care if you're anymore
we're
you know as much as uh you know yeah
proprietary technology and all that [ __ ]
it's like just it wouldn't it be nice if
it's like can i borrow your charger you
have to ask what charger do you have
yeah what a society we would live in bro
what's that mean with like the flying
spaceships and this like
civilization this is civilization this
is where we would have been if everyone
agreed on usbc like years ago that's
literally like we you know it's just
basically everyone and then apple which
is just how things are but also usb
definitely suffered from all that [ __ ] a
while back as well with micro b and and
micro oh yeah yeah yeah
and then usbc came along and everyone
was like this is [ __ ] and then i was
like hold up it's actually it's actually
not that bad that's good yeah you can
plug it in either way
it just it just works and where people
were just like what you can do that
solves an issue
but yeah no i think uh buying this
firing was good i like the camera that's
that's all that's good about it you know
you know i'm just kind of a big fan of
yeah going back on the like auxiliary
thing and just proprietary things that i
miss it's just a lot of the times i
don't really see a point in buying a new
phone i i normally just buy a new phone
most of the time because the battery the
the battery life just gets [ __ ] right
but i was completely fine with my old
phone if if the battery if the battery
life hadn't reduced over time i would
have still kept my old phone because
what are what new features are you using
your new phone for that you're not using
your own old phone i will say one thing
this is just a youtuber thing being able
to have a somewhat good camera in your
pocket if i need some b-roll or
something or i need like a little vlog
bit is super useful that's that's the
only reason why i updated to the new
iphone the camera on
i don't have to log around a huge dslr
all the time and also i'm a big tech
nerd right so i want to get the new
stuff so the fact that it lines up is
like a justifiable reason in my mind for
work it's like a it's like a no-brainer
for me like i'm gonna do it now this is
the first year in like five years where
i i had i didn't upgrade my phone after
one year yeah i waited really yeah i
normally i did it every year i don't
know why i just found that i must have
been buying [ __ ] phones that kept
getting too fat i used my phone a lot
yeah like more than the average person
i'd say i'm playing videos on it
non-stop
and uh yeah this time i waited two years
and i i really felt it in the last year
because like my god was my phone being
[ __ ] yeah but what was it what was being
[ __ ] about it uh battery was the main
issue obviously yeah i mean that's the
always the main issue but i was
definitely getting like the cpu slow
down issue where like stuff was getting
slow
sometimes i would press the lock screen
button and more often than not it just
wouldn't open
and then sometimes it would open but
then i've been pressing it so much that
now it was buffering all the opening and
and that i was trying to do and it would
like just start spazzing out so
a lot of issues
does it does happen to you are you
kidding me it definitely does happen to
an iphone i've had
i literally had an iphone and then i
switched to samsung because i was like
encountering too many different issues
the reason why i changed to android is
because my my iphone was just being so
[ __ ] temperamental like it was
breaking so much really that was the
opposite for me my samsung phone was
being so [ __ ] that i changed back to an
iphone i guess it depends like on which
phone you get right this is like i think
the last one i got was like the six
iphone six yeah
quite a while ago yeah yeah yeah but
then that's because i i done iphone four
five and six
and i was getting more and more annoyed
with each generation like [ __ ] this yeah
fair enough and i just i just like i
just like the customized customizability
that you have with the server it's
really easy to like it as well download
apps that you aren't supposed to on
android that aren't on the app store on
on on
on apple it's like built for the bad
boys on apple it's like hey do you want
to just like
like do a criminal offense in some
countries and load your warranty a
warranty in every other country uh by
jail breaking it it's like you know it
kind of sucks i you know and sometimes
you don't i don't want to chill i didn't
want to jailbreak it i just wanted one
thing that i had to jailbreak it for and
i was like okay well that's [ __ ]
i just didn't jailbreak at the end cause
i was like i'm a good boy fine you'll be
a good boy
i'll be a good christian with android
it's just like just download the apk and
then install it yeah is uh that phone
bigger than your last phone because i
noticed it was like chunky boy when i
held it yes yeah
i like the visor though i like this like
daft punk
is it not it's got like mad deaf punk
vibes i like that see it looks kind of
like a focus
i know it doesn't look like [ __ ]
among get the [ __ ] out of here this
you know what you know you should get a
red case for that yeah
you know i was i've been waiting for the
pixel 6 for like i was like i'd watch
everything like why because like i i i
got sucked up into that like you know
i'd watch the marcus brown lee's i'd
watch the whoever else there was
everyone who isn't marcus brownlee
because no one else is like marcus brown
that's how it is with youtubers it's
like marcus brownlee linus tech tips
everybody else to the normies right yeah
i know there's other people i'm just i'm
just joking but like austin evans crying
right yeah yeah
but that's the thing right my mom can
watch marcus brownlee my mum likes
marcus brownlee's videos right and i
don't know what it is because somehow he
makes tech very approachable to like
absolutely anybody yeah like when i
watch lana's tech tips it's good but
it's definitely for someone who like
likes their tech yeah yeah you have to
have knowledge um and like there are
some other ones as well who are decent
but i think marcus brownlee somehow just
gets the perfect balance of like
appealing to like enthusiasts
would but also appealing to like my mom
yeah
yeah i don't know right so that's how
that's probably why he's just so
successful there as well yeah i mean
like when i was like
gonna upgrade my phone i was like should
i should i move away from samsung and i
like started watching a lot of tech
videos like comparison videos which is
the best phone to get in 2021 and then i
watched like several like [ __ ] 20
minute long videos comparing like the
samsung to the iphone or the pixel one
yeah so let's see
and then i realized i have no idea what
any of these guys are talking about and
like the difference that i'm gonna find
is gonna be minuscule with everything
i've just found out that with most of
those videos at the end of it all
they'll give you all these like tech
rundowns of like yeah it's better in the
iphone but better on the samsung but
then at the end you'll just be like yeah
so uh which one's better it really
depends on what you want to use the
phone for really uh
the samsung is like 0.5 better at taking
pictures at nighttime so if you're going
to take pictures at night and i'm just
like if you're a night photographer only
here in my mind i'm just like well i've
never taken pictures at night but maybe
i'm going to start in the next year you
know
this is this might be something i need
to like pay attention to and i'm just
like and then after like overloading
myself with information i just realized
none of this actually [ __ ] matters
all that matters is the [ __ ] price
point and the [ __ ] the [ __ ] your
personal choice and your personal choice
clearly the camera clearly doesn't
[ __ ] matter because every single
video of any public event with a camera
ever seems to be in 360p so like clearly
the people who are at these like [ __ ]
walmart fights don't have the newest
iphone filming in 4k hdr because that's
i i don't see these fights in 4k that's
true
people aren't uploading tick tocks and
like [ __ ] 8k resolution although our
phones can shoot ak resolution i don't
know when we'd ever use it you know
what's weird is that i i've had so uh my
last phone was the pixel 4 right before
that i had the oneplus
7 pro yeah whichever one had the camera
that like manually came out like it was
a motor but the camera came out oh yeah
yeah
and to this day that's still like the
best camera used to filming on my phone
it was better than my pixel 4 and it i
think it's still better than this
because it can do 4k right and it can
that you can change all the settings
like
in in the camera yeah
i had to buy new phones when i moved to
japan oneplus doesn't work in japan
because japan has its own
type of frequency waves or something
that it uses but no other country uses
we're not like the others yeah so if you
want to buy a phone you you know make
sure i i'm pretty sure like none of the
chinese phones work in japan no that's
not true really i used a huawei phone
here
it works yeah oh okay well oneplus
doesn't work so there's a few other ones
in particular i think like i think oppo
phones i don't see them ever here they
they do sell them really yeah i've seen
phones i wonder was it just [ __ ] one
plus then it's literally just [ __ ] one
time to be fair i hadn't heard of
oneplus until you bought one you started
raving about it i i i've never heard of
to be fair
it was really good yeah and then
recently their phones have been coming
you are the only person i've ever known
that's owned a oneplus okay if somebody
owns a oneplus they're normally like
they follow like tech stuff because it's
definitely like a tech person phone or
at least it was like it was like it was
like really good specs and stuff but for
a good price right and then now they
just do what everyone else is doing just
like good specs for high prices so that
doesn't [ __ ] fair enough yeah i mean
that's just like that's i i'm not i
don't pay too much attention to the tech
world i like i pay attention when i need
to buy something new yeah it's the
problem with yeah it's wrong with phones
right like you you
as much as i think like the galaxy fold
looks sick it's like i didn't want to
buy a phone at that time and then by the
time i want to get a phone i probably
want to get one that's newer so that i'm
not getting like is the galaxy fault
even worth it what's what looks sick
what's holding your phone that's the
unique selling point apart from just
headphones
imagine the power move where you text
someone and you [ __ ] slam your phone
right afterwards you're like [ __ ] this
person
that's the same thing with the motorola
they they came up with a new smartphone
as well where you can just like it's
basically a football but it's just so
it's a fashion piece it's a fashionable
yes but like so is everything in your
[ __ ] life
well that's why apple makes so much
money right it's yeah yeah even though i
like there's some things that apple make
that i don't like like i have have you
seen have you seen the conference video
of when apple announced the price of
their monitor um
you know when you're making a
presentation and you know you know the
audience isn't going to be happy and
it's just like us and uh so the monitor
army is going to be priced at 999
dollars and uh moving on and uh it's
like like
you can just tell how nervous he was and
how much he had to like
like mentally rehearse that in his mind
before he said it out loud me listing my
christmas list to my mom right now as a
child it's uh 200 anyway the other one
is ten dollars it is a pack
one thing that i've never understood
right i i use smart watch right i got
small wash right yeah i hate
i i think that apple watches look like
toys i don't understand why people wear
them like to be fair i think they look
kind of ugly as well they look they look
like a toy they look like something that
like ben 10 would wear yeah except
that's cool it looks like something i'd
raise like pokemon on you know like
i mean everyone wears them yeah but like
i like the scene
i don't like square uh square watches i
like the smart watches that look like
watches because then you don't look like
you're like you're about to go to
silicon valley and sell stock you know
what i mean like yeah i don't know do
you like do you want to look at the
apple watches
i mean i i'm very indifferent i don't
wear watches i don't wear smart watches
i wear smartwatch but just because i
like the buzz it just buzzes i don't
look at it i just want to know
because i put my phone on silent see i
don't like that because i get like i get
bombarded with enough notifications on
my phone that sometimes i just need to
like put my phone aside and be like okay
there's a separation but to me if i wear
a smart watch then i'm constantly like
getting bombarded with notifications and
you know that's why that's why i stopped
wearing a small watch i just wear the
jojo yeah just because like again like i
want to wear my jojo watching i also
want to ruin it i mean yeah i'm scared
to like ruin it value yeah same man i
guess but but it's like i don't know i i
hated i liked the smart watch at first
because i was like oh cool i can [ __ ]
see everything without opening my phone
this is great maybe it'll stop me from
getting on my phone yeah it didn't
well actually it just prolonged the
process of me actually pulling out my
phone it's just yeah but i know for me
personally it's helped where
i don't always want to
99 of texts i don't reply to immediately
and i want to find out do i need to
reply to this so when i feel a buzz i'll
just check all right not important all
right yeah i don't i'm not getting my
phone out i'm just going to carry on
yeah that's kind of what i do you know
for me because because we do get
bombarded with a lot of notifications
emails like twitter whatever but i just
want to like
when i'm trying to be productive i want
to just like get all this done in one
point like i want to reply to all my
messages within one point look at all my
notifications at one point and then just
leave it aside but like i feel for me if
i had that constant buzz on my [ __ ]
wrist i just wouldn't be able to
concentrate because i'd be like is this
you think so at first yes
you do but then after time it's like
anything you just kind of become numb to
it and sometimes i've i've been buzzed a
bunch i don't even realize it but
doesn't that completely defeat the
purpose yeah
i think i need a bit like building a
taser or something
[Applause]
he never replaces like a shock dog yeah
i think so like
yeah i don't know and also honestly i
kind of like how it looks i don't know i
like this that is a nice wash yeah right
like it's one of the ones that looks
decent so i i yeah something about the
it being square
makes it because the watch in your mind
is like ingrained as a circular shape
watch is circular right yeah so like
when i see a square i don't know what it
is about my brain that just thinks that
that's just a construct of your mind
right that is well that's
just how like just
stand should cost less than a hundred
dollars is a construct of my mind
i think
just expand your mind
it's not just a pc case that costs a
brand it's a cheese grater just just
just just wait circular monitors
the future is now think about it yeah
yeah
we make our watches square and our
monitors circular
i i i watch either is it all nice well
now but you are square watch what do you
like about the square watch
to squirt
nice he likes squares like it's like a
spongebob on your hand yeah
you know i feel so strongly about that i
mean for me like tech has always just
been
application and functionality like i've
i've i've never really cared too much
about
having the newest tech as long as i get
something that gets me my work done or
gets me something yeah just gets me that
gets me the functionality that i need
and i guess that's just like
that's just like my engineering mind
like i don't care i don't care how it
works i just care that it gets the
[ __ ] job done yeah it's just me
maxing his life you know i think that's
why this new phone's annoyed me so much
is that
in like a in like a from specification
level it's amazing and it's got some
really cool features but the one thing
that it pisses me off is it just
sometimes little things are being
annoying on this yeah the generation
that's what pisses me do you know the
biggest thing that pisses me off about
this phone it's such a minor thing
what's the phone by the way uh it's a
samsung
s
21 okay yeah s21 um so what do you think
the power button is
oh is it below the volume no so the
power button
is you have to press these two buttons
at the same time oh
it used to be it used to be this button
but what's this button it's the bixby
button and uh
bixby is like meant to be like the
samsung equivalent to like siri but i
don't know a single [ __ ] person who's
ever used bixby no one likes in my life
i've just heard about bixby about five
seconds ago you know what likes people
no what who the [ __ ] is bixby no one but
samsung puts it in everything rugrats
character
it is yeah it is
it's like meeting someone who uses bing
you know like like who who are these
people who are these people i'm still
using ash jeeves actually i mean that's
good
android right but this is what they've
been pissing me off with lately every
time they add something they take away
something or change it a lot right so i
remember on my old phone used to be able
to screenshot the whole page so it would
scroll down and then for some reason one
day they just removed it they didn't say
why why would you remove that and then
not add anything to like replace it and
now they've added it back in with the
new one but for like two years i lost
the ability to screenshot the whole page
that's right that's the selling point
right you're being sold on new
functionality it's a classic apple a
classic apple and then
and then i remember when you wanted the
screenshot it was used to be simple you
i think you just press the power button
down and then it would like oh no you
could press like a combo and you could
screenshot and then they change it like
hold the power button down and then you
press it to screenshot something like
that i can't remember exactly but like
they just change [ __ ] for no [ __ ]
apparent reason and then they call it
new and i'm like [ __ ] off
it's not new if you just made [ __ ] more
complicated for me [ __ ] off and yet he
somehow still is part of the system wow
you're part of the cycle you're you're
you are trapped you are trapped it's
trapped in the tech side
you win they've made you angry and you
can't get out i just like android too
much you know and i don't really have
anything to to go because i think a lot
of the time with apple
the reason why people are quite loyal
and you know i understand this is that
they buy a lot of apple products yeah
they have the uh well that's why you
bought the pixel right because you're
part of the google yeah
yeah
yeah but that's because like team google
android works well with windows and you
know stuff like that it all kind of
works well with each other you know and
emulation is easier on android and all
that except isn't it weird that the
pixel doesn't work with the chromecast
now it doesn't but chromecast is
google's thing yeah so i don't know so
you think the one phone that would work
with something google related would be
the google phone whatever this is yeah
why did they remove the functionality
yeah because i can i can control it i
can control it with the controller yeah
so now what i have to do and i want to
control that instead of going to volume
i have to go to google home app scroll
down oh my god scroll down
yeah i know scroll down to the to the
the device i have three devices in my
home as well so i have to click it and
then i have to go on the volume slider
and it's [ __ ] stupid i don't know why
google did this [ __ ] like it's like they
[ __ ] hate me you know they're already
paying my bills with youtube like why
are you making me stop with google i'm
already trapped so what does the volume
button do
nothing normal volume so it's your phone
volume yeah but normally when you
chromecast things it would
you'd be able to choose all of the
volumes yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
sometimes i can still do that on my
samsung yeah because sometimes i'll
for whatever reason if i'm feeling like
a psychopath i'll play a video through
my phone cast a video and then maybe
i'll be on call and i can control all
the three volumes separately yeah i do
that sometimes
welcome to an influencer's life
we've become that meme of just like the
guy who has like four screens looking at
like the stock market or something
instead of talks four different videos
it's just memes
you need to like consume all the memes
at the same time i did something one
time and i was like the [ __ ] wrong
with me i was just watching two videos
and both volumes were playing and then i
realized 30 seconds into doing it i was
like yeah i can't hear i can't hear it
yeah just listening to both at the same
time and trying to take them both in
like don't know why yeah there's no
apparent reason you're challenging
yourself no i wasn't doing it
consciously i just did it by accident
and i just didn't stop it i was just
letting them both play and i was like
this is good need some more sleep i i
have an issue of uh opening too many
tabs and sometimes yeah i've seen some
some sometimes sometimes one of the tabs
is playing volume and it's like [ __ ]
trying to find where's wally in in the
[ __ ] tab section it's just like which
one of these is playing [ __ ] music
right how many tabs on average do you
have open okay okay okay okay i'm not a
psychopath i've seen like i've seen some
people who have like a hundred or like
you know how can the browser even run at
that point okay i've seen tabs when it's
just like it gets like 20 tabs and then
you have to like click an expansion to
get like the next 20 times that's just
like a [ __ ]
like 50 tabs it condenses it down into
one drop down yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
like 30.
it's like 30. too many too many yeah so
what what i do is if it's like 10 tabs
and i you know in case i don't want to
close one of the tabs i just open
another window and uh start start and i
stack them on top of each other now how
much ram is that using i don't know
how much ram do you have in your mouse
it's funny because when i'm editing uh
when i'm editing like even like
heavy like intensive videos right i look
at i look at the ram usage and google
chrome is like still more than my
editing software a lot of them close
your [ __ ] browser's gone
what if i need it what if i need it just
in case just
there's a thing called history
that saves it all yeah obviously you do
not know how many memes i have to go
through like like
maybe you should just view your memes in
like incognito or something that works
like not important because like what
what if i have to have like if i have
like one important research topic yeah
that i'm looking that i need to use
research
for like a video or something [ __ ] me
i have the one tab that is the important
research topic that i'm working on for a
video and then i have like 30 meme tabs
and finding that one research tab is
[ __ ] impossible
what if you just separate the research
into a different window
because because with the length that
memes last i'm always constantly looking
up i feel like you have
some kind of issues here just
you know putting them into categories
and actually i don't know organizing
your [ __ ] tab scan probably probably
probably that would help me yeah that
would help i literally try to have as
little tabs open as possible because i
just don't want tabs open if i have more
than five i start closing ones that i
don't need yeah yeah five is like the
limit five is a limited five is like
five is basic five
level one
i'll have twitter open emails
youtube and that's it really if i if i
have to have more than five tabs open
i'm opening another window
yeah on the other monitor just put it on
another one so you gotta tab for youtube
twitter emails um
something for music maybe or like a
video to play in the background
[Music]
they call me in high school uh whatever
you're searching i don't constantly have
like twitter open all my emails oh i do
i don't know how are you gonna go to the
fresh memes
i have my phone for that i have my phone
open constantly scrolling with the eye i
do the [ __ ] awful thing where i have
twitter open like i scroll i i scroll up
on my twitter i see the completed
timeline close that open my phone and
open up twitter
oh my god [ __ ] dammit
oh my god social media has hacked your
[ __ ] mind yeah like i'll open the bbc
to read the news articles i'll close it
and then 10 minutes later i'll open it
again to see if anything anything else
yeah all right so so here's the thing
you wake up you open your phone what's
the first thing you check what's the
first app you open it's whatever the
notifications are really yeah
i kind of like look at is there any of
these which are like super important any
of these are they ever ever any super
important sometimes sometimes you wake
up and like shit's gone wrong or
something and you're like my line
messages really are the first
ones where i'm like oh yes this requires
immediate attention everything else like
whatever if it's email then it's not
going to be important no because if if
some if someone i don't know if you see
it if i see a video if i wake up and i
see an email from youtube i'm like okay
no that's a [ __ ] spot
that's when my heart sinks no no
youtuber ever wants to see an email from
youtube it's it's literally like you
never want to hear from your boss
if you get a youtube it sucks right
because sometimes youtube will email you
email you'll be like here's the
community roundup of stuff it's like
[ __ ] off youtube you scared me because
normally it means a copyright claim or
something so youtubers are scared to
death of seeing anything related to
youtube in there
it's like a copyright claim or worse
like your channel has been terminated or
your your video has been adressed yeah
your video has been addressed nothing
nothing good ever comes out of a youtube
email like i could like get a youtube
email being like we've decided to send
you one million dollars for being such a
good youtuber and i'd i'd like i'd still
get a [ __ ] heart attack or something
true
true uh
hmm
probably
i think i'd go through my notifications
first obviously yes i'll check it you
know line uh
i mean you know do you have multiple
messaging apps like that people can
contact you on do you have a personal
like number one priority app that one
that like this is the one where if you
message me on here i will actually see
it in reply uh yeah to me it's like line
and facebook messenger yeah facebook
messenger is like that's a [ __ ] lie
you don't respond to your life
well that's
i respond to messages when i check my
messages and i i do not check my
messages when i get notifications that's
that's what that's just what i have to
do you're like my friend from i read a
friend from school right and he was
always kind of he's always kind of a
little odd but he's a good friend we
just play xbox a lot
but he was just always so stoic
and and very strange with like
communication
like we would we'd always play xbox
right but then summer holidays would
come around you'd be like all right guys
guys i'm just not going to talk to you
all summer and we were like all right
but he wouldn't it would disappear all
summer
and i was like okay strange and whenever
you messaged him you'd see him at school
you're like yo why don't you apply my
messages i didn't want to and i was like
we would be like what
what an [ __ ] yeah yeah
and then um at prom right
yeah we're at prom and uh we're like
we're just having a good time and then
we're like yeah dude we should grab some
drinks and i promise like i'm never
going to see any of you guys ever again
and we are like we're like wow we were
like what wow
and then but to this day
wow at least you can't say he was wrong
but yeah you know it was weird like
two three years later he messaged us on
facebook
and we played during the it might have
been when was fortnight popular
what did four when was the engine like
the biggest thing two or three years ago
yeah whenever that happened yeah i
played like a few games of fortnite one
day and then haven't heard from him
again
so
that was that's interesting last online
nine years ago yeah well actually i i
know what he's up to because my friend
is
my friend's dad is best friends with his
dad so yeah so i i i he he's yeah he's
alive he's doing well he's doing well he
doesn't want to see you
you know i get it some people want to
move on after school i get it but like i
don't know to me it was like damn this
man was sure
it's not like he was getting like
bullied or anything
we were his friends we were literally
his friends well clearly not we hung out
with him more than anyone and the
scariest decided that he was just done
he's like friendship over you know this
man like just did the irl friendship
remove in front of us and like and like
we thought he was like joking friendship
with connor ended fortnight is my friend
now yeah we met up with we i met up with
some of my friends back in the uk who
were there was the two friends so we had
a friend could be four of us and it was
the three of us and not him uh we met up
and we were just like yeah that was
weird huh how he just he really was a
man of his word to the end ah he
really just uh just disappeared he
literally just went through his facebook
friend list and we entire around and
we're just like guys i'm gonna i'm gonna
start clearing off my friend list
if i unfriend you don't worry about it
it's just weird right because he he
didn't delete and he was on facebook and
then yeah i think if i messaged him he'd
reply but he just was like i'm never
gonna ever make an effort to talk to you
ever again
it's true the man knows what he wants
right in some ways i respect the
conviction i i wish i had i wish i had
that amount of conviction at age 18 to
decide to make a life choice like that
to just cut people out
this episode is sponsored by apari an
artist own apparel brand featuring
original content except this time
they've collaborated with krypton future
media to bring an officially licensed
drop with hatsune miku
oh joey what is what is that i see is
that drip no joe i don't think you're
dripping you're leaking right now well
i'm glad that you think it's drip con
because this is a two-part collection
and this is only part one no not two is
coming soon so if you don't want to miss
out follow aparri's instagram which is
at aparri art and mailing list at
aparri.com joey also model for the part
one pieces which is this collection and
i'm wearing it this is the hatsune miku
hoodies oh yeah you can see you can see
the back right here and oh this this
fabric feels good man did you know the
miku shirts are 100 cotton and their
pigment dyed or tie-dyed i can actually
feel it and the miku haori is 100 linen
and the button-downs breathable and
lightweight they're made of eucalyptus
and bamboo blend eucalyptus that's from
australia and the hoodies heavyweight
and 100
cotton so if you want to get any of
these items please check the link in the
description thank you gepari for
sponsoring this episode now back to the
show bye yeah i mean i mean how many of
the people you still
like met at 18 or friends with in high
school do you still keep in contact with
high school
uh like actually a a fair amount
occasionally just because it was very
small yeah i still have like a facebook
group of like all my friends it was a
really small town so it's a lot easier
to
you know you you knew everyone yeah and
you know your parents know everyone so
it's really hard not to like have some
form of like oh this so-and-so is up to
this and stuff yeah that's that's weird
for me because i remember whenever i go
like visit sydney's hometown in sydney's
family should we
just be like go shopping to a
supermarket or like going in town and
she'd be like oh yeah she uh taught me
history in high school oh yeah
friends with the [ __ ] small town
and i'm just like i can't imagine ever
like running into my teacher in in
normal life because if that happens like
in my city it's like defcon 5. you know
he's like no actually no the students
reached out okay but then he like he
liked me so he was like hey connor yeah
come on over come on in and so i can i
can just like
walk in so here's the thing right i'm
speaking to an american and this is so
okay this is this is gonna sound like
another conus american story yeah we
were sitting there and i and uh so they
were from florida
and uh we were talking about this and
they were like wait so there's like no
security at your school i was like no
there's no security at my school
they're like what if like something bad
happens i'm like bad things don't happen
at school yeah this is school
what do you mean like the teachers can
handle it yeah what do you mean it's
kids it's like it's fine like what if
someone comes in with a gun no one has
guns but nobody knows no 12 year olds
have guns
like this like there's no metal
detectors no no that's crazy it's so
alien you think we can afford metal
detectors yeah we can barely afford
chairs
we're like we've been using the same
chairs for like the past 80 years in my
school we don't have chairs
like if you're in a school and you had
to open up the textbook and you didn't
have to share your [ __ ] textbooks
yeah you knew you're in a good [ __ ]
school yeah yeah so like i could like
you know i could if if i was going in
you know one of the if i just said one
of the teachers is like gonna just ask
me to come in you know even if they
don't know anything i just i can just
walk in and be like hey the
school told me i was i was coming and
they're like oh okay cool because they
like know who i am yeah so because i was
a next student yeah and even if it's
like a good school it's like the most
you have to do is maybe like you know go
to the reception and say like hey i'm
here for dude and then you can just go
in right you don't have to go through
this whole like prison scene yeah yeah i
was like
what do you mean you don't have to go
through the tsa every time you go to
school yeah and then when i was done i
just went around to speak to the
teachers that i liked and i was like hi
how are you doing are you doing well
nice yeah nice cool cool how's life yeah
i'm still teaching cool god
nice imagine going to school that's
actually safe yeah
oh my god worst thing that happened was
[ __ ] me climbing a tree and then
nearly just jumping out of it and uh
that's the worst thing happening
i thought he was like you getting into
fights or something
did you have to go to detention for that
like what punishment system did you have
in your school
nothing physical i assume in this
i think some of the teachers would have
loved to though yeah some of the older
ones i could tell
they were more than happy to try it like
undoing the belt
now now
um yeah did you guys have detention in
your school yeah of course we we had a
thing um a couple was called him welsh
what is it you sit in a room
facing a wall
it's like a tiny tiny room yeah you just
face a wall
yeah we had the same thing where our
teachers would just tell students to
just look at a [ __ ] corner
like go stand on the wall right
and that's how it was until i entered
high school right because to me the the
word detention that was an american
thing right that was an american
punishment yeah us our school was in
britain we just stood up we just looked
at a wall
we looked at that we called it blair
witching
you know whenever i got into f i think i
only went there once and that was from
one of the fights yeah but most of the
time i went like full lawyer mode when i
was a kid i was like hell no your honor
you hit me first there is no way i'm
doing self-defense
and then i think one time they were like
you need to go to the headshot like i'm
not going to detention they're like what
do you mean why am i because you hit me
[ __ ] i'm not going in detention and
then they were like hmm
i think i i i would have gone in
detention if they actually made me do it
yeah right you know
but i was like trying to fight back and
what the [ __ ] did they didn't make me go
see like i didn't have the balls to like
retaliate i think what after i got in a
fight like adrenaline was like high yeah
i think i was willing to fight back
because most of the time i'd be like
okay i think the reason why i could
never retaliate to my teachers is
because like in my head i was like
if i did that to my dad for instance
he'd beat my ass
to say that the teacher's not going to
beat my ass as well all right that's why
like i was conditioned
same thing like if i know that if my
teachers called out my parents which i
did multiple times i would get [ __ ]
violated they would kill me they would
actually kill me they would like take
away my xbox for like two weeks and i'd
rather frankly sure death they honestly
could like could leave me out to dry
with no food yeah easy right i'll do
that here take my xbox away for two
weeks all right real [ __ ] right now okay
now now i'm gonna do anything possible
to your voice they never told me that
there was a fate worse than death
i legitimately they could take away they
could like starve me for three days i'd
be like as long as i have my halo 3 copy
and halo reach i'll be fine
legitimately i'm pretty sure i would
have preferred that yeah
so i avoided it but i know the one thing
the one thing that my parents would like
have my back on is if someone started a
fight with me and i fought back so i was
always very confident right right i was
like yeah were you do tell my parents
yeah they'll tell me good on you they'll
be like my son's good
like did he win
[Music]
i'll pull some water on me though get
back in there go back in
[Laughter]
it's genuinely the only things where i
felt like i could get away with doing it
because my parents legitimately would
have my back yeah but that's why i
didn't mind fighting max i knew that i'd
you know if i
if i genuinely felt like i was in a
position to fight back i would
it worked but you know i wouldn't
recommend it for everyone yeah
if you're if you fight back and you lose
it's that's that's a different thing
right yeah yeah it's almost terrible
you're going to be bullied by everyone
yeah
the kids watching this it's hard high
risk high risk high reward right
not even high reward
it's just high risk
yeah that's just high risk just high
risk yeah we spoke about that much there
yeah all right i need a piss connor the
psychopath i gotta make peace
you know how we were talking about like
a few weeks ago how like in like 10
years we're going to be laughing out
[ __ ] bass boosted braille like morse
code memes or something so like i think
i've already reached that point because
i was i was watching a meme the other
day and the meme is just like called
gamers in 2030 and it was just
it's already
it was just that scene from wall-e right
with like the kids on like the tricycles
or whatever and it was just them looking
at sorting algorithms i don't know why
it was so funny
it was just
it was just
sorting algorithm and fart noise
i feel like i have to see this
my sense of humor is so
i think i was just like i was more
laughing at the fact that i found this
funny or it was just like a [ __ ]
laugh loop yeah but just just kept
building a lot
i literally can't explain the science of
why i found this funny because it's
[ __ ] it makes it makes absolutely
zero sense yeah
speaking of memes you know what i
recently invested in what let me show
you boys
oh yeah oh yeah yeah i saw that i got
the goku drip jacket how much was that
you don't want to know yeah you don't
want it
really
so i is it official yeah
oh okay
so so i think it's it's estimated value
is like
estimated value yeah the same way that
like nfts are worth value yeah yeah yeah
it's like i think two and a half grand
right i managed to found it on uh yahoo
auction or some [ __ ] right
for like a grand where it was like it
was like
ripped and torn
and they showed a picture of it and this
japanese standard of ripped and torn on
the sleeve it's like a tiny bit ripped
and so obviously they'd like gutted the
price because of that and i was like bro
i'll take that for a meme i don't mean
it not gonna lie the jacket's kind of
sick
i bought it specifically for a meme with
a video that will come out at some point
yeah like i i i was like i'm gonna wear
this maybe i'm probably gonna wear it
much i probably just get it for the beam
then i might wear it outside but now i'm
like okay you need to wear it out i kind
of like this yeah i wore it and i'm like
okay yeah
this is actually dripping i understand
why finally how's the
i was dream
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] sick finally
something to rival the jojo's
somebody says i i i don't have drip i
just threw money at the problem money
made it go don't even think about
fashion i literally bought the
definition of drip i bought the goku
jacket
i i was gonna get the supreme shirt as
well but [ __ ] that knock off yeah yeah
sounds like a thousand dollars i'm not
buying that for a [ __ ] shirt the coat
at least there's a north face coat yeah
so at least it's a decent coat yeah but
i mean still it's way overpriced what it
is though jesus it's north face though
it felt very high quality though but not
a thousand dollars
you're gonna wear that like when you go
to like snowboarding well yeah oh dude
imagine snowboarding yeah that's what
i'm thinking that's what i'm thinking
man
i'd be so scared to like rip it or fall
on it though because like dude what if i
[ __ ] if i rip that jacket though that's
the most expensive [ __ ] piece of
clothing i've ever bought in my life
yeah that's insane well
like what was i going to say like going
back to your yahoo auction thing yeah
i've just noticed that whenever like a
japanese person goes so like they say on
their second hand store that it is like
bad quality or is like a little ripped a
little something it's it's not at all
yeah it's basically new because i had a
similar experience because i just
recently bought um a gilgamesh watch so
you know how we have like the jojo
watching so they recently uh they before
that they did a collaboration with um
with you know fates and fake characters
so i bought the gilgamesh one and it was
like really really discounted because on
the website it said um scratches and
dents right and i'm just like and i'm
just like okay whatever i just i just
want it because it's a gilgamesh
so i get it and the scratches and dents
which was like one little dent on the
corner of the box and one scratch on the
[ __ ] box itself yeah right that's
what that's what put its price down it's
it's it's not even on the watch itself
it was on like it was on like the
packaging which i'm not even going to
show off anyway right yeah
japanese secondhand is not secondhand
it's like 1.5 yeah yeah yeah it's weird
because some websites uh there's other
websites like
yeah that have ratings yeah and like
it'll be like triple a which literally
means that it is probably better than
the [ __ ] factory quality yeah yeah
like you will like mint conditioner it's
literally like insane yeah a a is like
very good like a store quality um you
know and then a a just normal a is like
good like i've bought so i think the
jacket was listed like a b or something
right and i was or like ba yeah
something sync b yeah and then it was
like it was fine it's literally fine
yeah but it was like and it was like
stained but i looked at it i couldn't
even [ __ ] find the stain that was in
the photo so i don't understand what
what's happened yeah i i used mirokari
once to get uh like that crt tv yeah oh
yeah and like
[ __ ] it like okay so i bought that for
300 bucks yeah right which i was like
okay you know what decent decent oh yeah
turns out later i found out like
normally for good condition that thing
is usually like five grand oh my god and
the only reason it was 300 bucks is
because
it was owned by a dude who took perfect
care of it wow and i was like
what why you could have easily extorted
me for a couple of grand at least for
this yeah yeah it was like 300 people
japan's one of the only countries where
i think a lot of stuff you can just like
just get it secondhand like you don't
really need to worry about it like don't
yeah clothes i've noticed online are
like insane conditions somehow i don't
understand how i wear an angle of
clothing once and it i look [ __ ] it
looks like yeah like
i wash it once and i'm just like this is
a wash clothes i can feel it i can see
it i don't understand like i i don't
know what i'm doing wrong maybe maybe
i'm just like a neanderthal with my
caveman machine i suppose even when you
go to like book off right and you know
you go to like the second hand clothing
sections and it's like this is clearly
like old clothing and it's been slashed
down but you look at it it's like
yeah what's wrong with it
also video game consoles oh yeah yeah
dude it is insane how easy it is to get
like nintendo 64 games in box for less
than ten dollars yeah like you see super
mario 64 in box everywhere yeah and it's
like 500 yen it's like five dollars for
an inbox copy of super mario yeah i i've
i've got one and it's not like 700 yen
yeah it's insane
it's actually insane like and you can
get nintendo 64s in box for like 20
dollars yeah i got mine for like 30.
it's it's it's absurd like and it's
actually stupid the only consoles that
are expensive are stuff like the neo geo
yeah um and some sega sega saturn is
usually some of the sega ones yeah but
like nes snes there's so many of them in
box and and so many of them outside of
the box so you can just get like a
plastic bag yeah with a perfect
condition n64 or an nes or snes for like
ten dollars it's insane and you can get
like the [ __ ] uh limited edition game
cubes for cheap i know they like the
orange one is that i got the orange yeah
yeah that's like 60 bucks 80 bucks
basically like japan is just a
collector's dream because there are so
many like rare items that you can find
here
for like mint condition like it's it's
actually insane how good they take care
of their stuff like i open something out
of the box somehow i get a scratch on it
immediately
exactly right
like like my hands touch it and it just
like i leave some kind of mark on it i
don't know how it's possible so i don't
know how these like how these guys are
taking care of these mint condition
everything every every item is just so
careful with stuff here yeah yeah i you
know i i'm not saying i'm reckless i'm
not [ __ ] throwing them everywhere no
but i think they go to an extreme level
of care yeah to make sure everything is
perfect and it's kept proper yeah
because like even the books right even
the books you buy a book off or
something normally when i when i read a
book you get like the natural bends with
it right somehow the books are like just
perfectly straight like mint condition a
lot of the time so i'm how how are you
doing this are you like reading it with
a tweezer are you like
is this like is this like a csi crime
scene or something where they're just
looking on the gloves they open it for a
second take a picture of the phone and
then read it on the phone
i can't increase it
yeah it's actually insane yeah i i don't
know
i don't know like how they got this kind
of culture around them but that's good
for us because we can find so many
things here you know find some rare
items get a cheap cheaper drip jacket
for a ridiculous price i think i think
it's because in japan especially it's
like the whole idea of like not so much
recycling but i guess like the whole
idea of oh if i move or you know
something happens or if i run out of
money then like i'm gonna have to like
resell this [ __ ] so i think a lot of
people just buy it naturally to just
with the intent to resell it yeah
because like i feel like i use it or not
yeah i feel like resell culture at least
outside it's just to me to me it was
like never worth the time investment to
try and resell something unless unless i
knew i owned something that was like
super super valuable like most everyday
stuff i'm just like i don't yeah most of
the time you just throw it out yeah
exactly it's more it's more effort to
sell for example maybe you'll use
clothes i think it's because it's such a
[ __ ] pain in the ass to throw
anything out here in japan yeah like in
like into like trash yeah and also you
have to like pay for anything even
remotely big yeah exactly anything
bigger than like 40 centimeters yeah so
it's like why would i pay to get rid of
this thing when i could just resell it
and make money to get rid of it yeah and
also when you want to throw something
away in japan you have to book when you
want to throw it yeah yeah and it takes
like a month yeah yeah so when i uh when
i was in my old place i bought uh the
toilet but in the new place there was
already one installed so i didn't need
the the bidet sorry yeah um so i had to
throw it away and i had to wait two
months to throw it away yeah so just in
my apartment just collecting dust for
two months before i throw it away isn't
this insane two months i had that with
my uh like desk as well and everything
like tables and everything it's like oh
cool 40 days from now i can throw that
throw out this piece of [ __ ] i don't
need it anymore oh new case you just
stick it on gumtree for free and someone
would come around and take it
i mean there's sites like that in japan
as well they're just not like really
readily available like almost like known
about yeah and also probably not the
best for like foreigners if you can't
read japanese yeah i guess you could
probably you could probably make it work
without google translate oh yeah but you
know you could probably do it on like
middle cutting and stuff like that right
it's probably why it's so
so popular yeah true and true yeah i
i've realized now that a lot of websites
can be
figured out
once you just you know you you have
google translate or whatever and like
most of them work exactly the same way
as most websites work so
you know it's a big deterrent because
once the rest of the world figure it out
i'm sure people can be buying like way
cooler [ __ ] but but now it's like we
have all the access to it so uh yeah
might as well use it well yeah i mean a
lot of the sites are popping up with
prop proxy shipping so yeah
on the podcast so yeah i mean a lot of
the time you are getting a [ __ ] steal
yeah i think the hardest one actually is
just yahoo auction yahoo auction it's
like i know the language and i still
don't know i've got it set up so i can
use it now but like i have to memorize
like some kind of weird like simon says
which panel to click on for which there
yeah because it's not like amazon we can
just like oh buy yeah right like you
have to like bit it's not bidding it's
not you you bid you bid but there is
also buy now so it's like ebay it's just
literally ebay but there's an etiquette
and this is where i [ __ ] up because
now my account is poorly reviewed
because i didn't reply saying i got the
item yeah oh yeah i just you know i
assumed that he got the confirmation the
package had been sent yeah and so he
wrote like a really angry passive
aggressive review in google translate
that why
asking why i didn't [ __ ]
say i got it right and i was like i
don't think it's that big of a deal is
it i mean i'm sure i didn't reply it's
all good right yeah you did your job i
paid you the money and it's fine because
he gets the money immediately so yeah so
you think that if you got the money then
that means it arrives safely yeah yeah
yeah and also it was weird because you
can't use a normal email for yahoo
i don't have anything notifications set
up so i didn't see it so but i i got my
jojo figure so
i got my jojo figure is that the only
thing you've bought of yahoo auction
thing right oh no that's miraculous
sorry oh that's me
yeah um there was tons of it but the
prices were like totally wild and also
getting the size was difficult i want to
get an l size yeah uh because the jacket
so i don't mind if it's a little big
because it looks cool strip strip
um
but uh
all the ones in japan were s or m yeah i
couldn't find anyone who had a [ __ ] l
and there was one that was l and it
happened to be the cheapest one so i was
like when this is this is an absolute
because no one's big enough here to wear
the hill yeah right i was like this is
amazing fantastic oh yeah that's great
that is the big problem about just
clothes sizes in america i'm not not in
america it's just in japan
america's just in my head all constantly
i know in in she said that in this like
it was pre-programmed
right she's american
it's just muscle memory it's like i'm
sorry in america but actually i'm not
i'm not [ __ ] on america right now
no yeah like uh especially shoe sizes
shoe sizes are like [ __ ] i can't buy
shoes yeah i don't know [ __ ]
impossible
specialized store and just like pray
pray that they have the shoe size i
found the only i'm like the maximum yeah
the only store i've ever found in japan
that has shoes my size is the abc modern
shinjuku oh yeah that's like that's like
which is where most of the foreigners
are but like you gotta go to where all
the foreigners are like i can't buy that
[ __ ] online i can't buy it like anywhere
outside of shinjuku
it's it's [ __ ] stupid like because
there's so many like amazing collabs as
well that like the [ __ ] new balance
collab that they did with ava yeah they
were so pissed off because they had like
these nice ava shoes and i was like oh
what size does it go up to and it's like
oh 26 i'm like you haven't need 29 and a
half it's really small yeah 26 is tiny
no i i wish shirts and like shirts came
in like sizes like shoe sizes
right i i i do because okay you get an s
you get an m you get an l a logistical
nightmare what does that what does that
that means different things depending on
what country you're in like okay well
well we should have i agree that we
should have some form of uniform rules
on what s m l is yeah yeah but then i
guess not every country would agree
because you know the the normal in
america is
totally different like japan i get an l
in japan it's too small like the first
jojo suits i bought it was an l right
and it was too small yeah right i get an
l in the uh in the us it's like three
sizes too big i'm just like what
like at least with shoe sizes it's a
number which i can correlate to
something yeah in with like shirt sizes
and suit sizes it's it's like a [ __ ]
free-for-all depending on what country
you're in and you and you have to hope
you have to hope that the store you're
buying from is a local japanese produced
store if you're buying american shirts
in a japanese store then you're still
[ __ ] because you're buying american
sizes so you've got to make sure but
shoes do the same thing you have uk
sizes you have us sizes you have jp yeah
but there is there is a conversion chart
for it so it's like all universal shoes
i've never had a problem with like i
know if they have it in my size when i'm
buying clothes in japan online it's it's
a [ __ ] model man i'm just like
is it the m or the l or is it the ll
[ __ ] i could be either one man it could
be no the worst the worst ones are the
ones that don't even use like s m or l
they're the ones that use like one two
three four five and i'm like what does
that mean
what
what does that actually mean and i'm
just and they're just like oh we have
the convert we have the size conversion
chart on the website and i'm just like
who the [ __ ] uses a size conversion
chart for t-shirts do you know a single
person who wants to buy a t-shirt and
they're just like all right let me get
the tape measure out all right yeah so
what's the shoulder width of an
emphasize i hate the whole tall short
nonsense with coffee as well oh yeah
yeah like tall is not the biggest one
but it sounds tall and then grande is
medium and then what's the what's the
big one venting
the [ __ ] does any of this [ __ ] mean i
get it i get it's italian right yeah but
like [ __ ] that yeah
just do small medium large extra
we've had this like you know we don't do
some we don't do like [ __ ] hot or
cold in some other language we just do
hot occult and why you know if the rules
aren't uniform in the coffee shop or
whatever why are we changing the [ __ ]
rules what's up with that
agreed upon standard into like your
[ __ ] passion project for your chain
you know what i mean i hate it that's
that's why until i got [ __ ] used to
the whole like especially starbucks
sizes because i never went to starbucks
in australia when the first time i went
to america and i was like oh yeah i'll
get the tall that's that's the biggest
one right i got this pissy little thing
and i was like all right next time i
went i was like uh biggest size please
big size big size so i i you know in the
uk sometimes i would order the venti
size because it was it was it was
reasonably big yeah i did
one time i made the mistake at anime
expo of ordering venti size and
starbucks in america yeah and i swear i
heard [ __ ] boss music playing when
they were like serving this [ __ ]
drink to me took like four of them to
[ __ ] hold it up there's a massive
french market it was like one litre of
ice cream in this frappuccino i was like
[ __ ] hell how many calories is in
this i went online it was something like
2
100 calories or something
2
100
holy [ __ ]
you haven't touched your bucket of ice
cream yet what's wrong honey you haven't
touched your oreo baskin robin's 2 000
calorie milkshake it was insane how
could they serve this how is that legal
i don't know yeah
on the flip side though cough coffee
sizes in japan way too small oh my god
oh my god this is the biggest one this
is a large size this is a
this is a standard large size that you'd
find in any japanese coffee shop the
biggest they have like but here's the
problem right in japan sometimes this is
normally what i always want now this is
like the size that i've gotten
accustomed to and i actually quite like
it it's like a good amount yeah you feel
like i got a good milk to coffee ratio
yeah and now i always order the largest
thing they have because it's normally
like this yeah but then i get caught off
guard when you go to a place yeah and
you order the lodge and then it's like
oh [ __ ] it's actually lost yeah [ __ ] i
didn't expect this
like there's no i don't know i have no
idea what the lodge is there's some some
some coffee shops mvps they have like a
little display that has the small medium
and large
how much coffee or drink i'm gonna
receive there are some places where that
like show you how many milliliters it is
right yeah yeah
those ones are like nice it's it's like
going to an
a an american restaurant in japan and
it's just like well uh it's an american
restaurant so is it going to be american
sizes or is it going to be japanese
sizes because if it's going to be
japanese size i'm going to need to get
i'm going to need to order an appetizer
yeah if it's american sizes you don't
need to order that the appetizer is the
meal yeah
yeah i ordered [ __ ] nachos at the
hard rock cafe yeah the nachos was like
my god you could fit like four children
on this plate
it was insane and it was just my
appetizer i thought it was gonna be a
little bit i could at the nachos and
everyone at the table could have eaten
the nachos alone and we'd been full and
there's free refills in japan yeah in
japan oh yeah that's that's that's what
gets you right because you know you
expect japanese sizes in japan but
whenever it's like american style you go
to some american styled restaurants and
they're still like japanese sizes you
know but you go to some american style
restaurants and they ain't playing
around they they're going all the way
they're all similar yeah yeah they're
they're fully assimilated to american
culture through and through
god i can i can just like imagine though
like i mean we're already used to all
right imagine like just like an innocent
like japanese girl being like oh i heard
about this thing called hard rock up
here
i'm quite hungry let's get the biggest
size yeah it's a [ __ ] mammoth because
it wasn't expensive either so that's why
i was kind of like
normally misleading normally like the
price to like if the appetizer is like
15 bucks yeah i'm like okay it's
probably gonna either be like really
high quality ingredients or something or
yeah pretty big and it's probably
normally pretty big yeah yeah and it was
massive it was gargantuan i could like
again i could hear the boss music like
[ __ ] zefroff theme playing as they
were bringing it out
it was like that meme of like the other
chess grand master versus the kid
like in the russian tv show it was like
that it was like
i heard you wanted a large so we
prepared a bucket for you connor it was
like
a quick time of it i'm gonna [ __ ] try
and do something to survive yeah i just
i just remember like the first time i
went to america it completely blew my
mind just like the scale of the meals
like i i just like i wasn't prepared
right because i had always heard i've
been smoking about this before like
right there's never-ending stories about
i mean
yeah because like i heard about it
before but i don't think anything can
fully prepare you for the first time
that first plate gets put in front of
you and you just think
this is food that i need to consume like
i remember i remember like the first
time i went to america it was like the
first week um and i i needed something
that just
wasn't just greasy or you know wasn't
too filling because that possibility a
heart attack you know by by that time
i'd like eaten like burgers and pizzas
and [ __ ] denny's whatever every day
so i'm just like i just want something
healthy i want something light i want a
light lunch um so we're at this diner an
oxymoron yeah yeah i we're at this this
diner and i was like what's the lightest
thing they have well it's possibly a
salad right there's there's no way you
can make a salad not anything but a
light lunch yeah and i was like i'm safe
i'm safe i'll order the salad and then i
remember just walking out and i see this
[ __ ] massive bowl in front of me and
i'm just like who the [ __ ] deforested
the amazon rainforest and put it on my
bowl like
how have americans found a way to make
salads unhealthy because like you they
[ __ ] drenched that [ __ ] in dressing
right and i'm just like what how i think
if you want to go any healthier than
that you just have to like get just a
bucket of water
you can't get any healthier than that
say healthy what's that you want some
water
this episode is sponsored by kossary god
why on earth did you have an air fryer
on the trash taste set because it's a
sponsor connor
what is this episode sponsored by kasori
it is wow kasori is a best-selling
kitchen brand on amazon and the
signature kosori air fryer and kasori
gooseneck kettle are right here right in
front of us
you know what let's take a look inside
the airfryer guys holy [ __ ] is that some
hot chicken wings damn are those crispy
without being overly oily may i
have a bite of it
smells amazing yeah it actually smells
really good let me give it a bite guys
is it me or is this just delicious
crispy and not too oily this kasori
airfryer has a quick basket feature
where you can actually detach the basket
from the tray with these damn sides out
of here and gamers we can't forget the
kasori gooseneck kettle has a precise
temperature control i mean now we're
drinking green tea and there's a green
tea setting right there so whatever
beverage you're enjoying there is the
perfect temperature controls option for
it oh
that gooseneck you get really like in
depth there oh my
now that is the perfect green tea
temperature hell yeah it is gentlemen if
you're looking for that perfect culinary
gift for that cooking your life check
out cossary's holiday sale on amazon
today links in the description thank you
costa for sponsoring this episode back
to the show i love wings in the u.s i
love wings
yeah but like you never know
oh my god
sorry
you never you never know how many wings
you're getting sometimes which is always
the hard part sometimes they don't say
how many wings you get right
which i hate and also some of you don't
know how beefy the wings are sometimes
you get like final boss wings sometimes
you get like level one starter pokemon
you like buffalo wild wings i love
buffalo i feel like in america like
[ __ ] me man like
um because in the uk i feel like in the
uk and europe we have like regular size
wings or like normal like average sized
wings right because uh i've like
somewhere some places in thailand you
order like you order chicken wings or
you order like chicken and you're just
like man this chicken's [ __ ] anorexic
you know like
the [ __ ] meat off the bones man
basically it's basically frog's legs
yeah yeah exactly meanwhile in america
it's like oh is this an albatross
like this boy's got a
i don't know like i went to buffalo wild
wings once and it's like i don't know if
i like it or not i love buffalo wild see
the problem i have with buffalo wild
wings is that like they shouldn't call
it buffalo wild wings they should call
it buffalo wild sauce because there is
more sauce on that wing than there is
actual wing yeah okay okay one time i i
i've been a few times because i really
like going there i really like because
you get like craft beer and stuff as
well that's fine i feel i'm like i'm
already becoming a 40 year old white dad
i'm already on my way there i love
buffalo wild wings i love craft beer so
much and like wings go so well with it
yeah if it's bone or boneless i don't
mind i just prefer bone bone but i don't
know i just like i just don't like i
don't know the the sauce is like too
overpowering sometimes yeah yeah but
sometimes it depends on whatever
sometimes i have the audacity to be like
would you like extra sauce i'm like no
i'm good sometimes you get a sauce
that's so goddamn good you're like bro i
don't mind if they lathered this on you
know yeah maybe since the sauce i got
was like kind of me maybe like
buffalo wild wings in my experience i've
had a lot of sauces where i'm like this
is this is [ __ ] yeah maybe i just got
the [ __ ] one like sometimes like like
the honey mustard one sometimes honey
mustard is a hit or miss to me sometimes
it's done right sometimes it just tastes
like artificial as [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
um yeah you know what i really wish we
had in japan what
spicy food challenges we have like
there's so many big food challenges in
japan we do have spice food challenges
where like most ramen shops
are they like actual challenges that are
like we have a spicy ramen no there's
ones that are like actually really yeah
is that spicy for you joey or like
actually like
i don't know i think for you guys it
needs to be like nuclear level for you
to be like
that hits back i'd love to do a video
where i go to like a spicy food
challenge place but i haven't been able
to find anything yet i've seen a lot of
like there was like entire programs on
japanese tv that were about that i saw
one ramen shop that did spicy ramen yeah
but it it didn't like advertise it as
like if you complete it you get
something it was like we just have a
really spicy ramen you can order it oh
like i feel like the part of the charm
of the challenge is that there's like
you get it for free or you know you
right you know there's a challenge to it
yeah yeah yeah there's some kind of some
kind of reward there you know because
then i can like then i feel like the
video can like have a cycle if you do
the only one i know it's not in japan
it's in korea okay um there's this like
restaurant i think some youtuber did a
video on it but there's this restaurant
in korea that's like uh it serves like
tonkatsu yeah yeah but it's like
insanely spicy tomato and it's like if
you complete it within like a certain
time then you get i think it's like if
you complete it within five minutes yeah
you can eat there for free for six
months what and it's apparently so spicy
that there's only been one person who's
ever completed under five minutes and
the rest of them have gone home
and the rest of them have gone to
hospital what because it's so spicy
apparently when you walk into this
restaurant the first thing they give you
is a carton of milk and like uh stomach
like medicine
you want to do that joey
i'm good
what if i find one in japan do you want
to do it joey
just take a little sip you don't have to
eat it all just take a little bite maybe
i'm done
there was a part of me when when because
like i grew up watching a lot of those
kinds of like programs on tv and you
know it was hilarious i'm like there was
like one percent of my brain that was
like you should do it for a video yeah
yeah and i'm like curse you
content brain
because you'd actually be suffering for
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
great now that i've said it on the phone
bombarded
i'll do foreign
i'll do it if you guys do with me that's
sure yeah sure sure and just just to
show how much of a [ __ ] i really need
because people because when i had the
ghost pepper on live streams people were
like oh that can't be really it can't be
a real ghost pepper kind of it was a
real ghost it wasn't real
react yeah it's because yeah because i'm
white they don't want to believe that i
can handle it because i i've [ __ ] my
body by eating too much of these [ __ ]
peppers yeah but so but i feel like with
with a lot of white people
go ahead no no
no it's either like one extreme or the
other it's true because it's either like
people like you who've like actively
searched for it and they've just like
nuked their body or people who say that
water is spicy yeah yeah yeah yeah you
had all the hot ones sources right at
your house yeah yeah and i was like
lathering the hottest one on my burgers
and stuff and like it wasn't that bad
like it was kind of nice like it wasn't
that spicy like and now i watch the show
and i'm like
it's not that bad i want like coated a
burger yeah yeah i want to do the hot
ones challenge yeah but i'd have to like
pretend
oh she's getting kind of hot meanwhile
i'm just like
delicious no because i feel like i feel
like you'd have to like up the ante
because if you just take like one little
dab that's not gonna do anything if you
have if you like [ __ ] coat it then
you'll probably get some kind of
sensation for it i mean i completely
lathered a burger with it yeah it was
fine but i feel like i'd need like
what's the one that's like apparently
horrible it's like the extract isn't it
yeah that's like the extreme one that's
the extra sauce yeah yeah it's like it's
like pure capsaicin yeah yeah yeah i
want to try that
it's not real though it's just your
brain your brain making sure you're
right in it yeah like if you if you
think you're gonna go into shock you'll
go into shock
just don't just don't panic just stay
here just don't go just don't
it's not real pain you're about to have
a heart attack it's not a real heart
attack just tell your heart to stop
you're scared
just don't die
just get a strong heart it's literally
fake it might never matter it's
literally fake news
why do people die over bee stings just
just don't be just don't be allergic
just don't be allergic well okay a
beasting is an actual physical chemical
reaction there's not there's nothing
it's all is not a chemical reaction no
it's your brain it's your brain making
the the pain
you don't know that wait wait wait no
because i know i know it's like not a
single person has died from spice yeah i
think yeah i think it's it's it's it's a
reaction that your brain sends to the
receptors saying that you have pain but
there's no actual reaction going on
that's causing you pain it's your brain
telling your body that it's happening
but you can die from the shock
no can you not you could okay so
you you can you can die from going in
the chakra in general right yeah so you
can die from that but like
the pepper alone will not cause you to
go into shock it's like your brain you
panicking and freaking out will cause
you to die right that's like telling
someone who's having a panic attack just
not to panic but like you generally you
won't die from a panic attack unless you
like have if you're having like heart
problems yeah like because it's
impossible to die from a panic attack
unless they're like you have like
cardiac arrest yeah yeah yeah yeah but
like the odds of someone our age having
cardiac arrest is like super low yeah
you'd have to really have an unhealthy
lifestyle and also being an extreme
shock i think i'm correct in saying this
i could be wrong there might be doctors
watching this but yeah as far as far as
i'm aware like it's you know this whole
thing don't don't take our words for
this don't don't
i don't know what i'm saying the
opposite of medical advice
as far as i know this whole medical risk
this whole thing of like yeah you can
die i think you can faint but i think
you can faint from like being like i
just absolutely exhausted and freaking
out and panicking like but like i i'm
pretty sure you can't die from it are we
talking about spice
yeah okay i'm pretty sure if you're
healthy and you're under a certain age
and you know you have no heart problems
you'll be fine well suffice to say i
don't eat spicy food because i'm afraid
of dying i just don't enjoy it no i
understandable right like it's just gone
to the point for me where like when i
have something that is like particularly
uh if it's saucy or meaty
something about having spice on it just
elevates it so much no it does there are
some there are some dishes that i feel
curry especially yeah yeah some some
dishes i feel that are just made for
spice and yeah we can do the spice
challenge but like i genuinely
enjoy spices
it depends on the dish right because
like for example if you go to coco
ichiban they have like the spice scale
right
and you can get the level 10. that's
spicy but i feel like that at that level
it's just spicy it's not enjoyable it's
it's spicy for the sake of being spicy
like it just hurts yeah and it it it
just ruins the taste of the food yeah
i've heard between level five and ten it
doesn't really change in terms of the
flavor ah it's just more i normally get
seven when i go right it's normally like
a happy medium for me yeah 10 is just
like too much pain i don't i don't know
what they put in it at 10.
that's it i don't i can't explain it the
spice just feels artificial yeah it
doesn't feel like
real spicy just feels like well you're
just kind of adding some kind of
chemical to make this spicy i don't know
what they do to make it more spicy but
like with you know i grew up on
obviously thai dishes and thai food and
it just feels like some dishes are just
made
poor spice right
if you remove like the chilis or the
aspects of spice from some dishes you're
losing part of that dish in my opinion
right i saw a picture and it was like a
from a thai restaurant because
apparently thai's known for being the
spiciest foods in the world yeah i
believe it yeah apparently so and um
it's either like thai like indian or
something right or mexican maybe chinese
maybe like szechuan sichuan yeah
szechuan is like a different kind of
spice yeah it's like peppercorns it's
peppercorn spices like nums your tongue
um there was like a it was a picture
outside of a thai restaurant it was like
we will no longer give refunds if your
food is too spicy
and apparent apparently it happens all
the time yeah people have returned food
to thai restaurants is too spicy well in
thailand no in like uh america okay yeah
no that's how you know it's a true thai
restaurant yeah yeah that's the true
type yeah yeah yeah that i understand
that if it's that spicy you can't eat it
but at the same time it's like
yeah well you are ordering a food and if
you want the native food you are going
to get it yeah yeah like it it hurts my
soul a bit because at our restaurant in
my family restaurant we have to like
make sure the spice is less spicy dishes
do you offer like the original like
spices of course of course if they if
they ask for it but you know my part of
my soul does they can speak thai yeah
part of my soul dies inside just knowing
that we're serving less spicy dishes to
everyone because they can't handle this
man because that's that's just that's
just not the true dish and to me to me
it does like it does actually hurt the
flavor to me it's like actually like
having sushi without wasabi or something
you know you know you eat sometimes i
don't have wasabi
you don't always need the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] hurts my soul hurts myself
wasabi sucks dick man it's awful it
tastes like [ __ ] well you're not going
to the good restaurant no sometimes i
want 100 yen for sushi man well that's
all that's what you get then that's what
you paid for get off my pants
man can buy a thousand-dollar drip shirt
but listen
that is a business investment i don't
hear it from you jay that's that's that
is
that is more than just a jacket that is
that is a historical art piece that i
purchased you sound like someone who
buys nfts no no no no
no you can't that is not just a gif of
young cat it is a historical art piece
you can't right click save that jacket
you can right click save and nft that
doesn't that doesn't apply this also
doesn't ruin the environment
um
this is this is a historical piece in 10
years this will be a monumentous jacket
that i will make sure everybody
remembers single handed
this is this is a piece of meme history
this is a piece of meme history i don't
know man it's like stained and ripped
secondhand right yeah
next time i go to your house
it's like a mona lisa right it's got a
it's got a story it's been robbed once i
had a little scuffs here and there adds
to the character of the piece so
i you know i that to me is not a jacket
it is it is an encapsulation of our time
and and meme history has everyone
screenshotted this for poorly aged
things
that is this is meme history if there
was other memes where i could buy a
physical thing i would buy it as well
what's a meme do you think that is
historical then that that that is
already historical yeah harambe no no no
no
no no no
no way that's a meme that is is if
you're a mima you know harambe
yeah but that's that's the same thing as
like [ __ ] that doesn't make it
historical it's historical
just because you know it
is historical
like there was so little memes at that
time that every meme is historical yeah
because like back back then you there
would be like 10 memes in the entire
[ __ ] year these nuts
these knots is a milestone of uh comedy
and memes yeah unfortunately there's
nothing like physical you can buy for
these
these nuts is an idea man it's a concept
it can't be owned by the people
it belongs to the people well the driver
can't be owned by a single person
the drip jacket the drip jacket belongs
to goku first and foremost and then me
second nobody else
can a meme really be owned though can it
can it be owned connor you could
participate in them
i'm fueling the i'm fueling the meme
economy
the meme economy if that jacket wasn't a
meme i wouldn't buy it
i don't think anyone would no
it looks kind of cool i mean yeah i i
think i don't know how much it was at
retail it might have been four hundred
dollars i think that meme's gonna be
around in two years
if it is and it's
like it's that that has staying power as
a meme yeah right because to be fair
it is like the drip goku meme has
weirdly lasted a long time
yeah because it pops up a lot yeah i
feel it's because you can fit it into
anything right yeah because it because
drippers last it goes hand in hand with
the drip if it drips around goku drip is
around yeah like what means because he
is the embodiment of the word drip yeah
like what memes has prevailed for like
the past two years has there been has
there been any major probably these
nazis lasted like a very long time
because these this god
it's like minecraft it died off and now
it's laughing like it's like having a
resurgence man it's just
minecraft music minecraft song who's
this who's that guy who sings minecraft
songs really badly
what there's a guy who sings like i know
minecraft parodies something he sings
really amazing minecraft parody songs
with a [ __ ] mic
it's amazing that sounds funny is that
the same guy who made the fortnight song
no chug chug with you yeah yeah that
didn't last long that lasted like two
months remember that yeah i remember
that yeah
because of the nfts right yeah well nyan
gets history just because at that time
it was inescapable it was inescapable
and there wasn't anything to compete
with it you if nan if neon cat came out
like today people would forget it in
like a millisecond yeah we should do a
three by three of memes we should we
should
i don't even think harambe was like that
funny though no it wasn't funny but it
was it was just around for a while and
it came back a lot did it yeah
most popular memes of all time most
popular i'm trying to i'm trying to
remember like funny harambe memes troll
face
well i mean i guess so that was like the
beginning but now that's just like
cringe that's boy i love that boy dude
oh [ __ ] what up it's that boy
i still have a dad boy that makes me
feel like a [ __ ] boomer yeah oh my
god i still have a i still have a
t-shirt of that boy no is it weird that
you think of troll face and you you feel
like a boomer you think of that boy you
definitely feel like a millennial yeah
that's that's like a generational meme
gap but they're still both like still
cringe now i don't know something about
that it was just like a funny image like
you couldn't use it in any memes the the
only time i ever saw like a dad boy meme
that was actually funny was like someone
uh took like the movie poster for uh the
boy in the striped pajamas and just
called the dat boy and striped pajamas
the only one that made me laugh
everything else is just [ __ ] stupid
it's like it's a frog on a unicycle i'm
going through all of these what about
rage comics is that a meme yeah is that
i mean that's the ogs right yeah but
like the troll face and all that yeah
forever alone is pretty iconic
420 69 all that stuff that's is that a
meme i think so 420 is a meme like
straight up i guess and 420 is
somehow prevailed even though it's like
not that funny
it's kind of like just like a public
holiday right now it's the closest we're
going to get to a meme public holiday
right the one day we come together and
celebrate
april the 20th
i'm going through all of these do you
think like our kids are still going to
be saying 420
oh god probably
i hope not
i'd probably probably gonna find a
cringe right hey dad
420
say shut up son
[Laughter]
you did not know the meaning behind that
word but i feel i feel like sometimes
meme come memes come back around and
become funny again right because i've
you know with ancient with the ancient
memes twitter account i've i've found
rage comics funny again for like
it's it's like ironically funny now yeah
right rick rolling
the most classic and
unexpected no not unexpected it's always
expected it's the most long-lasting
prevalent meme yeah and
this one's obvious but like pretty much
every [ __ ] spongebob screenshot
yeah
if any show somehow spongebob has the
most memes it is a meme factor and
they're good yeah they're good they're
really good
like think of all the some of the
funniest meme screenshots like 50
percent of them from spongebob that's
true that's true this is insane he was
ahead of his time man spongebob was
spongebob invented me built different
man yeah i i guess in terms of the
long-lasting it's probably yeah 420 in
my mind spongebob and probably rick
rolling are some of the three most
powerful
yeah influential
influential you can't own them you can't
own them you can't own them belongs to
nobody connor belongs i'm gonna have to
make drip goku stay around for a long
time single-handedly i can get some like
investment but like okay if you try to
sell this jacket in like a year right
it'd be worth more right if the meme's
still popular if the meme's still
popular i'm not gonna salad though yeah
i'm i'm owning this you're hodling man
diamond hands no i actually want to
why are we talking about the durability
of a meme i'm just saying like i you
know there are some memes that where i
like it's hard to gauge whether it will
stick around or not yeah yeah most of
them it's good 99 of them don't
like you remember how quickly the
[ __ ] cake meme died
what kicked me wait everything is cake
you remember that
yeah yeah but everyone was like this is
the new hottest thing and three days
later it's like what cake no that
prevailed for like a while what do you
watch do you think you guys don't watch
lesson in meme culture do you no no no
basically talks about memes and like
every single day there's this new meme
that i've just never heard of and dies
like within a day because they're like
weird-ass [ __ ] but like can you even
call it a meme at that point because
like sometimes there's you know so like
sometimes there's a meme that which
lasts a day you know i i feel like if
for me yeah truly has staying power it's
just like a week is like the minimum
yeah what's the line between a meme
i think you're confusing memes
on like there's levels of memes right
there's like the public public memes
where everyone is in the loop yeah and
then there's like only internet only
memes
where it's like only certain groups on
the internet do this meme what's what's
the meme name i i don't know what this
meme name is well i find it [ __ ]
hilarious it's the one where they take
stock pictures and make really shitty
jokes with it
no no no no like like like the one where
the boyfriend is looking behind no no
not that one like like like i hide the
paid how hide the pain harold stuff like
that no no no no like they take they
talk pictures and like for example
there's like a girl lying down and a guy
um and she says call me an ambulance and
the guy like the guy like neil's over
and he says you're an ambulance
i don't know why i find those so
hilarious but i don't know what the name
of that meme is because i want to find
more pictures and more memes in that
category
like the son and the dad are in the car
and it's like
oh we named your your sister after roses
because your mom loves roses he's like
oh what am i named after he's like oh
you don't you wouldn't understand 420
blazers or something yeah yeah like that
my favorite one is the honey wake up
that's a very popular yeah if anyone
knows the name of that meme please tell
me because i want to google it and i
want to find more man i just call those
like stock photo memes yeah but like
stock photo memes are so like
so wide and varied and broad because you
got like the guy looking back and i
don't count that you know
[Applause]
no because it's it's you know for me
what i'm talking about it's like a very
specific shitty joke that works because
you've got shitty stock images with it
have you seen the meme if you've seen
the same images in the same category you
won't know exactly what i'm talking
about it's just so hard to put like a
[ __ ] word and a name to it yeah i
don't know what the name is
i don't know
you're gonna have to show me these yeah
ah all right junior p yeah i need to pee
we all shop online and we've all seen
that promo code field taunt us at
checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past honey is the free browser
extension that scales the internet for
promo codes and applies the best one it
finds to your card honey supports over
30 000 stores online ranging from sites
that have tech and gaming products to
popular fashion brands and even food
delivery guys what did you buy i'm glad
you asked jerry i recently acquired drip
it might be hard to tell i don't know
but i recently got drip and i saved a
significant amount of money thanks to
honey here's how it works tell me
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites uh-huh while at the
checkout the honey button drops down and
all you have to do is click apply
coupons oh my gosh wait a few seconds as
honey searches for all the coupons it
can find for that site
if honey finds a working coupon your
watch as the prices drop
so what are you doing get your drip
honey has found it's over 17 million
members 2 billion dollars in savings
so guys what are you waiting for if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's literally three and it installs in
a few seconds and by getting it you'll
be doing yourself a solid and supporting
trash tasting the boys so what are you
waiting for get honey for free at
jordanhunting.com trash taste that's
join honey dot com slash trash taste
dinner honey for sponsoring the episode
back to the show so league of legends
yes what about i'm just gonna drown
myself real quick what about it so joey
have you heard of this uh new anime or
animated series um called arcane is the
league of legends
it is it is the i've seen it i've seen
pictures of it yet okay so at the time
of recording only the first three
episodes are out so it might have been a
massive failure after the next six came
out yeah so we don't know but the first
three episodes
it looks and was really [ __ ] good
like it's
really it looks good yeah the visuals
are insane it is genuinely like i i came
into this because i i you know me and
kind of both play league you know we
both talks yeah we're both very toxic
gamers in that sense and every time we
talk about league joey just like just
like conks out um so what i was
expecting was just a mediocre video game
fantastic
yeah fan services adaptation i just
wanted some cool fight scenes basically
just like an extended version of the
league cinematics you know what i mean
and uh i would have been happy but uh
like i watched the first three episodes
and i was just so unprepared for what i
think is like
one of like so this is just watching
three episodes it's legitimately like
the best three episodes of like any show
i've watched this year i can't think of
like a show that just has a stronger
start i agree it was like oh my god like
it the visuals are like pixar level of
like detail at times yeah yeah into a
like a nine episode show yeah i just
don't understand how they're doing it
like the animation is insane yeah joey
look i know you've like quit anime and
everything like that but but i i swear
to god this is something that even if
you have zero interest in league it
literally doesn't matter even if you
[ __ ] even if you [ __ ] hate league
you don't you don't you need zero
[ __ ] knowledge about the game because
it's all about what i love that focuses
on like the character and worlds um
because what this what this series made
me realize is that league actually has a
really [ __ ] interesting world and
that's what really drew me in which was
there was so much thought that was put
into the world building and the law
which is like
league law was like um the meme
foreign kept rewriting it because they
would introduce characters and i don't
know so they had like this mess of like
characters that people really like with
really interesting back stories
but they didn't really know how to like
connect it and then they just literally
at one point just gave up yeah they just
stopped doing it yeah they're like
no one's reading it they should do like
articles all the time do you remember
and no one read it
because it was a
i mean it did make sense but it was just
so confusing and hard to digest that the
only way people consumed it was through
youtube videos of people explaining it
yeah i think most players didn't really
care to begin with right now yeah
exactly
no one's playing league for the law no
no no it's like how many how many like
curse words can you say per minute
instead of how many how many how many
character laws do you know you know it's
different but like i i think you would
enjoy it if you give it a shot cherry uh
it's it's it's not like league at all
really really not
the only benefit you get of being a
league fan is that your character's
names come up where you're like oh i
know that character yeah but then in the
show they're like nothing like the
character no no so it doesn't even
[ __ ] matter it doesn't matter because
a lot of the times you're guessing it's
like is that is that that character is
that that champion but most of the time
they're just characters in their show
which is which is what i like right they
don't they don't like fan service
certain characters because they are
characters in the show a lot of the
times there there is just this world
that exists and some people in these and
some people in this world happen to be
league characters and that's it's it's a
show where i feel like it just
it it
you don't have to be a league fan to
enjoy it and it prevails
with
like mass marketing league as a
franchise as opposed to just the game
and
it's like honestly the only video game
adaptation i think that even like stands
close to it is castlevania it's like
castlevania level of like
like video game adaptations i just have
to see where the next six episodes go
but like right now god damn god damn
very impressed it was interesting
watching watching a show like this with
a twitch chat though because yeah yeah
you'd have these like really really
serious moments going on and then you'd
watch twitch chat and everyone's just
like juggle feeding me jungle feeder
fk adc fk and i'm just like okay okay
it's pretty fun but at the same time is
it ruining my viewing experience i'm not
quite sure
it was like genuinely like a
movie quality experience watching this
thing yeah like in a tv series like
everything was so on point like the
sound design was insane the animation
especially like i could go online about
how good the animation is and the voice
acting is really good like everything so
far has been good like yeah absolute
bangers like i know like the meme is you
know lol netflix
netflix live action adaptation but man
netflix video game adaptations are
[ __ ] knocking it out the park man so
far so far so far so far again i'm
really hoping that this doesn't age
poorly and yeah i'm really i'm really
hoping
but like because like the episodes like
as well like you you know at one point i
thought oh we're getting a predictable
story and then it just kind of like
flips you on its head yeah i was like oh
oh [ __ ] okay
what about oh jesus
that's really good really really good
like what other video game adaptations
have they done because i know
pennsylvania so far right castlevania
netflix yeah netflix
it was bad yeah oh yeah it wasn't it
wasn't good okay there's a bad game too
well
done a fans of seething
yeah
i watched a little bit of the daughter
anime and it wasn't good why just
because i was curious you should watch
the league out of me because you're
curious i'll add it to my watch list
please i i've never wanted to watch an
anime more than this watch it later but
please it's good you know you know joey
i i actually would prefer to use like
for you to watch league animation than
to watch any anime this year
it's actually good please give it a shot
it's actually so good be sure to check
it out oh my god
getting this guy to watch anime is like
[ __ ] impossible
refuses to watch an anime
i guess i guess it settles it though you
know league better than dota right
checkmate donor fans well one thing that
league has always been good at was
making anything but league game
thing we got gamepl insane yeah all the
time [ __ ] was [ __ ] dude yeah i think
about the [ __ ] everything they've
made outside of league is amazing like
like
in terms of aside from the game i
remember when kda first came out and i'm
just like
what the [ __ ] league is cool now
and i'm like that lasted for a week and
it was like the most surreal week ever
everyone was like yeah apparently
yeah yeah
it was like the one week where like fake
league fans came out where it was like
cool to play league and then
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] inescapable oh it
was
yeah i don't play it anymore you're not
a big deal and kda came out and he was
like yeah i'm a league player yeah yeah
because i remember i was actually uh
because kda debuted at the 2018.
i think you'd
[Applause]
that he was there when kda premiered
yeah no because people ask me because
whenever i whenever whenever i meet some
things people ask me did you work at the
bbc and were you with the lawyers
whenever whenever i meet a fellow league
fan i'm just like oh yeah i was at the
2018 uh world war ii and i [ __ ] roll
my eyes when i
then and then people ask oh how was it
and i was like oh kda was great and then
they ask oh how's the match i'm just
like oh kda was great
because i can't remember anything else
because that was the only highlight
yeah we we didn't just get like we did
we didn't just lose we got [ __ ]
obliterated okay so katie
that's what matters that's that was that
that was worth the ticket cost of flying
all the way to [ __ ] korea korea was
great i want to go back to korea
league worlds may have ended but the
real [ __ ] was the arcane
end of league worlds i sleep arcane real
[ __ ]
bro please jay please i'm begging you
just give it a watch i'll watch you no
please actually like i've never known
something more in my life i will
absolutely watch it
yeah honestly honestly uh if if there
are any
viewers watching this who are not a fan
of league even if you hate league please
watch arcane you know if if if it
continues to get even better than it is
right now which i i would be impressed
if it does yeah genuinely it was going
to be like a [ __ ] hood class i want
to be surprised it's going to be a
certified hood classic i wouldn't be
surprised though because like every as
you said like everything that they've
released that's not the game has been
amazing like even for people who don't
give a [ __ ] i don't understand what's
going on i don't understand why riot
still pretends to be a gaming company
because i would welcome
okay so that league in the law
has so many different like actions and
uh like i guess eras
different areas that completely have
characters that don't even ever interact
with each other and they're focusing on
a certain area now that has certain
characters like if this kicks it out the
park i'm just excited for the
opportunities of like we could get the
league universe yeah yeah the lcu oh
i'll be i'll be [ __ ] down
i don't know anything about it but i
know there's like a great war yeah yeah
that was like that could be [ __ ] hype
bro like it's the first
like like to arcane has made me care
about league law like after i watched
arcane i i started reading [ __ ] wiki
articles to be like yo
it's that good joey it's what else can
we explore yeah it's such an such an
interesting world and there's so many
opportunities for just like different
elements to clash together because there
are some league like right now we're
focusing on like human characters in
like a city you know but there are like
there are other cities other
civilization and then there are just
like [ __ ] gods in the league law as
well yeah there's like which other
characters yeah which i'm thinking if if
they can like
integrate that somehow then it is
literally just the mcu all over again
right
yeah yeah i i could just see it there's
just like the [ __ ] like you know how
like uh spoilers for ngo i guess you
know how like captain america just gets
his hammer they could be [ __ ] like that
i guess yeah just like i don't know
zack turns into a blob i guess
there's just like there's some random
ass characters as well that i would love
to see how they would integrate there's
a character in league right called tom
kenz right his whole story this
character is that he's just a massive
what is he a frog or some [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is tam ken i think he's a frog a
massive frog-esque thing yeah he just
lives in a swamp that eats humans and i
just love and he has no connection to
like any of the characters ever like
pike i think it's just like how would
you in how would you include a character
that just eats people like that how
would you do that i'd love to see it but
it's amazing because the best thing
about this character is that he speaks
in like a really thick southern drawl
right right
like a small guy it's like it's just
like i don't even know what some of his
lines are he's like this is my swarm
i don't know he's just like i'll give
you a daughter or something like that i
don't know it's like really interesting
i don't know i'd love to see how they
integrate these weird-ass characters in
the league
i don't know i don't know how it is for
the viewers just seeing joey pretend to
try his hardest to like care
if he sits and explains arrow games to
me i think it's okay for me to sit here
and explain league law
look forward to my uh in-depth review
for next week's episode which is
definitely coming legitimately if you
watch it i think you'll actually enjoy
it okay like legitimately he'll come
back and he'll be like guys i've made a
mistake
we're just gonna keep talking about it
until like he'll just have to like
buckle one day i'm gonna read one piece
and he's gonna watch this
[Music]
that's the comparison
yeah okay
sure this is easy to watch you get a
treat watching this i've just
through one piece
but like yeah i legitimately think think
it is one of the best things i've
watched this year like anime or not it's
like i i can't even think of how many
things i've just sure if that's telling
of this year's content or not we've
actually had some pretty good stuff
we've had some good stuff this year i i
don't know because i'm just like i don't
know
[Music]
i'm trying to think of all of the things
i've like read and watched that's come
out this year
i can hear the dial up yeah
i mean it's it's been a lot i i i'd have
to like go back through because
yeah yeah okay like movies movies has
been not so much movies has been not so
much but i've barely released any movies
because yeah it's still the pandemic
yeah i mean actually they've really
geared up recently
i've watched a lot of movies recently it
feels like all the big movies yeah
they're just starting to come they're
just starting to come out now because
they were supposed to come out like a
year ago
yeah like like i know like there's been
some new mcu movies that i just haven't
watched do you care about the mcu
anymore you know i heard eternals was
like bad yeah tunnels was rated really
bad really bad yeah i don't think i'm
gonna watch it not that i ever gave a
[ __ ] about the mcu but i don't you know
the mcu now it's like okay now you need
to prove to me why i should care again
now that it's over like
like
to me it's like i i don't think they can
just coast off the success of the
previous entries i think yeah sure we'll
get like the the series that everyone's
gonna go and watch like doctor strange
and all that stuff yeah that's gonna be
cool but if they're trying to sell us on
new characters it's like okay how are
you gonna sell us now that there's no at
the moment there's no big thing that
we're planning towards yeah right like i
wanted you to watch like changji for
example but also i had no like incentive
to go out and watch it you know i heard
it was amazing though like a lot of
people said it was really good but also
but also i thought it was really good
but but again like you kind of like the
same thing where i'm like okay i'm not
gonna lie a little burn out on the whole
superhero thing yeah yeah like the only
thing i'm really excited for superhero
wise uh is uh batman with robert
pattinson uh just because i'm looking
forward to that i love robert patterson
i think he's so [ __ ] good in
everything i like the batman movies yeah
all the way moves are chill but like
because they've they've cast like what
everyone thought was quite an unusual
choice which like robert hatson is
definitely uh well i mean it's unusual
yeah have you watched any of his stuff
that he's been in like some of the indie
films that he's done i've seen one indie
film that he was in i forgot the name of
it but what was what happened in it
roughly do you remember oh no no okay
because it was literally the first indie
film he did after the twilight yeah so
he kind of obviously like he can't have
a bad rap from twilight because he was
like before he wasn't really he was
typecasted yeah yeah yeah and i love
interviews of him like [ __ ] on time
no no he [ __ ] hates him
you know he
wouldn't i can only imagine what it felt
like when he was like i am a serious
actor who trained professionally went to
like the most prestigious [ __ ] in the uk
yeah and now i'm here doing a [ __ ]
half dead vampire who barely emotes yeah
right and then he went on the whole kind
of like indie film uh like series where
he just did so many indie films he was
doing he tried to change his image yeah
and then he was doing really good
artistic films some of them were amazing
yeah the lighthouse was amazing if you
haven't watched that really amazing i
highly recommend it it's got a what's
his name um
uh yeah wonderful ryuk you may know him
my favorite word
amazing
and so far i've just loved watching him
and so i feel like he's probably going
to do something interesting batman that
i'm like a lot of type casted actors
though have like gone down there like
daniel radcliffe went down like a
massive indie film round because you
know everyone just knows him as [ __ ]
he's not busy [ __ ] kissing and
[ __ ] everyone on set yeah
i went on like i went on like a massive
binge of like daniel radcliffe like
indie films and like some of them are
[ __ ] amazing like kill your darlings
is amazing he did a lot of odd films and
he did a lot of uh he does a lot of
theater stuff yeah because he was like i
think it was quite a big thing in the uk
right after harry potter ended or during
harry potter he did something that
required him to be like naked yeah like
a horse or something yeah yeah yeah i
remember in the uk the tabloids were
like daniel redkip's a porn star now and
then like people are already trying to
drag him because obviously british
tabloids are like the [ __ ] worst on
earth yeah they're so bad but like drama
youtubers you know just just imagine if
every newspaper just turned into
keemstar yeah
basically
it's weird because i'm remember when
someone like leonardo dicaprio was seen
as the teen heartthrob you know the
titanic the titanic guy you know and how
hard he had to work to like change that
image even though even back then i'm in
aging right
no no but even back then he was like a
hell of an actor and i don't think like
i don't think people gave him enough
credit at the time i mean i remember
like it i mean i remember it was like a
prevailing joke where just like if you
ever feel bad about your day remember
that you have the same amount of oscars
as leonardo dicaprio you know i finally
got one he finally got one he finally
got one but now like now you see him
aged up and like
he couldn't be more different you know
he didn't age up he glowed up he [ __ ]
bought colonel yeah did you watch um
your superhero actually quite enjoyed
recently what uh the suicide squad not
suicide squad oh the suicide the suicide
squad there's two suicide squads there's
another one that released on hatred so
the one
better than the schneider cut oh my god
it's like did you watch the snyder cup
uh yeah it was awful i wanted to die
what is it my name is katana that means
sword or something in japanese that's
like the best line
is that a real lion yeah one of the
swords like her name's katana it means
sword in japanese
um yeah it's something along those lines
that could be misquoting uh yeah it was
really good idris alba's the main
character in it and idris alba is just a
a pleasure to watch always yeah you
always just kill it and john cena's
really good in it uh
he plays like a psychopath justice man
it's so good so yeah he he plays a
character called like peacemaker is it
yeah yeah and
he's just like a [ __ ] murderer but
he's just like it's all for peace it's
off a piece
and so he's very funny really good in it
really really really it just it works
and then he's getting his own movie now
peacekeeper really yeah john cena is
just like [ __ ] hilarious in every
role he's really good yeah he's he's a
really good he's actually a good actor
yeah yeah yeah
yeah the whole film was just really good
really fun really well made is it like
is it like a standalone thing or was it
gonna yeah stand alone completely uh
as far as i know they're not doing a
sequel i don't know though
because nowadays you just can't have a
superhero movie without someone being
like oh this is uh this is playing like
cinematic universe i think i think it's
just a just go watch it i guess you the
other characters like peacemakers
getting his own thing but in terms of
like this thing dude you can just watch
it suicide squad cinematic universe
starting turn your brain off like it's
really good does it have anything to do
with the original no because i watched
the original and i'm just like this is
the most five out of ten movie i've ever
seen in my life it's in the same thing
so like it's like the same premise but
good
so like it's just a soft reboot yeah
it's a reboot but like just watch it
it's one of those films where like you
don't have to pay up much attention all
right it's just turn your brain off a
really good time for two hours at which
point are we just going to not be able
to track which new like superhero
franchise is like which ones are reboot
which ones are building on to like the
cinematic universe
is the new batman film is that part of
the original is that something separate
or is that following on from like the
zack snyder batman i'm so [ __ ]
confused
as much as batman is a superhero i don't
watch batman movies as a superhero movie
it doesn't feel like a superhero movie
to me yeah
i kind of agree with that well that's i
feel like this ever since the dark
knight trilogy yeah because that kind of
like i feel like that kind of redefined
yeah you don't get the whereas you watch
a marvel movie you know exactly what
you're getting yeah and like to some
extent you do with batman as well but
for some reason when batman goes down
that route though they do it in like
kind of like a campy tongue-in-cheek
right like yeah you know like the george
clooney like batman around because it
because it's just like with batman
movies it's like i i always think is
this like a batman movie or a batman in
the you know dc universe movie like
where because if if they make batman in
a movie um that has to integrate with
the rest of the dc universe there are
some rules that you need to like
acknowledge you know whereas with where
if it's about standalone batman movie
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
yeah it's just a [ __ ] he's just a
[ __ ] weirdo
but i mean yeah i really enjoy the
batman movies and uh
again like yeah like i said when it
comes around i i i don't feel like it's
the same thing and
when i watch a marvel movie you kind of
they've kind of gone to this formula
recently that is kind of really boring
and
predictable where it'll be like all
right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna have the thing with the with the
really big stakes and we'll bubble crack
a few jokes along the way of course
we're a family-friendly movie and so
then now they've all turned into these
pseudo-action comedies uh in some
aspects like thor uh four ragnarok
really like led the way for this i think
after thor ragnarok like every single
marvel movie had to be funny i think it
was always like that
it was always like really turned up to
10. it was like you watch the like first
avengers and you're just like oh
everyone's got quips everyone's got
something funny but
ragnarok was more of a comedy movie than
an action movie did you watch it yeah of
course i watched it it was there was
more jokes than [ __ ] plot points in
that thing yeah but that's also what i
liked about it yeah i do too and but i'd
argue i'd argue like so it's like
guardians of the galaxy which came
before thor right i i feel like it's the
same kind of vein but but i just felt
like everything started doing that yeah
i feel like everything's just kind of
ramped up yeah i'm not sure if the
newest marvel movies are then like do it
or not because i haven't watched them
obviously apparently eternal just has
something like that i think thought
ragnarok is just that formula is because
he was directing it yeah because it's
that that's basically his formula
yeah but like yeah
was like doing the old like shakespeare
thing yeah yeah every single every
single goddamn marvel movie now has the
funny guy in it but someone who's like
just there to crack jokes you mean iron
man well yeah i don't know he doesn't
crack chat i mean there's someone else
like oh gosh geez i don't know what's
going on
terrible joke to do i don't know
like most of them like oh yeah who gives
a [ __ ] about ant-man
i think i give a [ __ ] about ant-man okay
that was a fun movie he's like the d
tier of [ __ ] marvel characters right
like
like literally no one gave a [ __ ] about
him well i feel like that's what they're
doing now with like the newer superhero
movies where like like some of them some
of them you watch and that you're just
like oh you're really scraping the
bottom of the barrel that's why
that's why i just like don't care about
marvel movies anymore like literally the
last good marvel movie i watched was
probably like iron man 2.
infinity war was just did you watch that
no oh it's such a good film like
infinity wars actually i only know about
the film through
is that the last marvel movie you
watched probably oh my god
well maybe like wait dude
no i just don't watch the [ __ ] marvel
film song because i just don't care
about superhero stuff
like
wait what wait uh [ __ ] deadpool was
marvel right
technically it was marvel but it was
also fox own but it doesn't feel like a
marvel film yeah yeah
so i don't know yeah well yeah because
it's kind of it's in the x-men universe
yeah it's in the yeah
terrible yeah yeah so yeah i mean
i don't i don't even even think x-men
was like that great of a franchise
because they've always struggled with it
they've always struggled to they've had
like some good films in the x-plane
franchise but if you take a franchise as
a whole and later in front of me it's
like
i think there's more bad movies than
there are good movies in the x-men
franchise especially the new stuff yeah
any movies out now you want to watch go
and watch god
i want to watch what's what's out in
cinemas right now
dude that's that's the one i want to
watch that's pretty much the only thing
that i've been hyped about um mate i
want to watch shangshi i guess when's
that coming out on like blu-ray like
i don't know it's probably might be
already out in dvds is it already on dvd
guys you still buy blu-rays no because
like when it's out on blu-ray that's
when it's out
in to the public yeah that's how like my
my mind [ __ ] works i guess i like
it's rare for me to go to a cinema to
watch a movie because that means i
better be hyped for this [ __ ] movie
yeah what other movies are coming out
this like this i still want to go see
belle normally the holiday period has a
lot of stuff coming out yeah the new
kingsman movie coming out oh yeah yeah
king kingsman is definitely uh i can
watch this at home kind of right now i'm
i'm not going out my way to watch
kingsman i want to see the new matrix
movie whenever that comes oh i'm
watching that in cinemas i'm watching
i'm watching that and since all i really
know when is the next john wick movie
coming out that's what i
is it actually soon uh oh wait sorry i
think they're still filming it so yeah
it's been like two years yeah come on i
need it it takes time to make a
masterpiece
he's he's enjoying the new john he is
donnie yen yeah yeah he took a selfie
with catering what
well i love donnie yeah he's great
so when you go to a when you go to a
screening and it's like a hype screening
like the new avengers movie you heard it
when it's full do you do you want do you
think
if the crowd is hyped up and reacts to
it and says [ __ ] yeah i hope that i hate
that okay look i think we've established
this before in the podcast actually yeah
we've spoken about this before um
i hate going to a cinema where the crowd
is loud yeah yeah me too yeah like
we've definitely said this on an episode
this is deja vu
yeah
yeah i said like i don't want to i'm not
here to see a [ __ ] concert i'm here
to see it on a movie so it's like i
don't i hate it when people are like
whispering be like oh this is the part
where this game comes i'm like shut up
shut up but like like when a hype scene
happens and like the the [ __ ] cinema
erupts
did you like it would you like it when
it happens okay when it's like one okay
when it's like at the climax yeah it's
fine but like when they're non-stop
doing it yeah like shut the [ __ ] up okay
yeah but like if it's like okay yeah
like the cnn game when he gets the
[ __ ] hammer all right sure everyone
everyone everyone lost that [ __ ] i hate
it i wanted to be completely silent i
was annoyed at endgame though because
the guy next to me would kept like he'd
already seen it yeah and so he was with
someone and he kept telling them oh you
got this part's gonna be sick and i'm
like we're in the movie shut the [ __ ] up
let him watch it yeah you're telling me
i'm right next to you shut up
what do you think's the best cinematic
experience you've had then john wick
three john with three
ship was amazing i loved watching that
in cinemas the center was empty i had a
great time it was beautiful i watched
like the last viewing of the day it was
totally empty i got to like put my feet
up on the chair in front of me had
popcorn it's beautiful it was wonderful
i mean i said in the previous episode
but dune was [ __ ] amazing for me
yeah that was the best cinematic
cinematic experience you've ever of
recent time that i can remember yes that
was incredible honestly any any movie
with like a han zimmer soundtrack you
don't hear the [ __ ] soundtrack you
[ __ ] you feel it all that [ __ ] yeah
holy [ __ ] that dolby digital audio 7.1
[ __ ] your pants experience
my daughter like when i went to go see
[ __ ] uh inception in cinema
the first time you hear that dual like i
thought my colon was gonna explode from
how bassy that [ __ ] was this man must
like edit on like [ __ ] uh ipod like
first generation headphones like no way
can a men listen to that much bass daily
like that can't be
you must listen to them through like
some shitty earphones we can barely hear
it yeah oh [ __ ] it needs more bass i
think at this point he just he doesn't
listen he [ __ ] feels the bass
what if he like goes to the same like
[ __ ] that's how much bass i put in [ __ ]
i didn't even realize i couldn't hear it
[ __ ] more bass
jesus christ
got the subwoofers on his life [ __ ]
speakers i can't imagine
i'd like to think he's just editing off
a laptop speaker
like garageband or something
he's a little more bass i think why hans
zimmer's house doesn't have any windows
imagine it your hands
imagine being han zimmer's neighbor [ __ ]
bro
he's just
[Music]
it's 2am and all i hear is base
actually there's an alien spaceship
docking outside there's so much bass
going on nope it's
just hands hands man come on man you
know it's three a.m our kids are going
to school tomorrow can you please stop
we understand you're making the
soundtrack to inception it's not lit
hard but not right now this is retention
come on man this is too much man come on
please hand start you imagine if han
zimmer was japanese my god his neighbors
must think that there is like a
magnitude 6 earthquake every other day
was japanese
uh i would like to buy the entire
building please
how much rent is that
easy i got you zuma has to live
like locate his house in a place where
seismographs cannot pick it up
because it falls positive earthquakes
otherwise
he'll like set up like an earthquake
warning every other day
or he's recording audio
and zimmer's testing out his new
subwoofer
it's terrible oh my god
oh my god though it's [ __ ] amazing
man you know what uh you know what the
hardest thing about being an adult is i
realized all day
go on youngest one here so you said my
mom or something
i was like that's her
daddy what is it
something that you can't be prepared for
as a child something that you you don't
get exposed to menopause
yes
obviously picture it i was at my uh my
local bakery and uh i go to go and get
my favorite item
they changed the recipe they changed the
item it's no longer the same it's they
substituted the the
the materials that made this fantastic
piece of food what are the kids called
that again pain picker yeah yeah you
know no one prepares you for your
favorite food items at a fast food chain
or a food place changing i agree how do
you deal with that how do you cooperate
i can do one better okay so you go to a
restaurant it's a local restaurant it's
like a it's like a local you know local
restaurant that's not a chain or
anything it's just it's your local
restaurant right and then one day you go
there and for some reason you don't know
why the food just tastes different right
the food just doesn't hit as hard and
you can't you can't put your you can't
put your like finger on why until you
realize oh the chef's gone somewhere
else that food will never taste the same
ever again
we could because it was the chef all the
time that made the food taste good it
wasn't the restaurant myself i've
actually had that in japan once and it
was so [ __ ] tragic like i never
wanted to cry more while eating food in
my life i'm like this doesn't taste bad
but
my childhood it's just yeah over there
i i agree that's bad but i think the
fast food one's worse because the fast
food is like comfort you know you always
go to get the same thing with fast food
that's what you're selling points no i
think the local restaurant
no no it's it's like it's like uh it's
like a person who murdered your best
friend it's just wearing their skin and
then he walks into your house and he's
just pretending to be your best friend
and he's just like no your friend
so it's me so mcdonald's did this uh
this like in japan there's a problem
with with japan and you get these
amazing seasonal items or items that
come around is that they only last like
three weeks so when you find an absolute
banger of a food item on a menu yeah you
know the time is ticking but that but
like you're okay with it leaving because
you you knew the rules of the game when
you went in to order that you knew that
you were about to get hurt but you
didn't care you wanted that spicy you
knew the rules
when there's an item that has been there
for like ages we're talking like yeah
by the slice yes and then [ __ ] you and
then and then the food item changes you
have been doing this your whole life
you've been eating there you've been
getting this one item and it changes it
feels like a betrayal of the century
like you've got to murdered my family
you walk in you look at the menu and you
just say
what do you mean where is it gone why
would they do this this must be a
mistake i'll have this item they say
they don't have it i cry no this must be
a mistake please check the back check
the back there must be some left please
no i do still think the local restaurant
is the local restaurant it's the worst
you move you move all the time now you
have you experienced it though yeah it
was like a local [ __ ] move no which
one you call what do you mean you move
look if it's a local restaurant i'm you
move every [ __ ] two years gone
no no no i mean like the local
restaurant which is like the same people
running the restaurant it's just the
chef's difference but it's in like fast
food items there's some stuff that's
been there for like decades but they
change your local restaurant you'll only
experience it for like two years at a
time because that's why you live there
no no yeah
there's some that there are some
restaurants that are just like you never
find food as good as that again i i
where
there are some places like anywhere
anywhere you live anywhere you live
every two years or every year yeah but
sometimes you go back to the restaurant
oh that's that's the worst though when
you've been when you go back to your
hometown and there is like this specific
restaurant and it's just changed right
and you'll know you'll never get a taste
of your childhood ever again or you'll
never get a taste of that taste of home
ever again and you didn't know what
before you moved that you were saying
goodbye to that piece you were thinking
about indonesian restaurant at my local
mall in australia the moment that
disappeared i was i had to like hug my
mom
it was like losing a family member i
still think when they change an item of
groceries or fast food is worse because
that's something you have all the time
you know like i remember i used to get
dairylee dunkers all the time in the uk
yeah even as an adult it's like this
like i don't know how to explain it it's
called great
it's kind of like um like fake
cheese cream whip um that sounds
disgusting no no no it's not like a whip
though it's like a cheese kind of spread
how would you describe dairyly duncan's
ah
describe it it's kind of like a
breadstick it's like a red thing that's
a bread stick in one part and then like
a cheese kind of esque thing yeah the
other oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah we have something like
that so they made they made that in the
uk right and but then i think they
changed their recipe when i was like 20
years old
they changed how they made the cheese
and it's tasted significantly cheaper
why are we eating that at 20 years of
age don't question why the [ __ ] i was
eating that 20 years because it was
really good like it was a really nice
snack it tasted amazing and i love to
get it and it was a blast of nostalgia
every time right and i know they had it
in my local supermarket and i would get
it and one time i got it i bought like a
full pack a big like a like a family
four pack i stocked up i was like yeah
yeah
i i i dug in right i open it up one bite
and i'm like
something has changed there's been a
disturbance oh geez
isn't that the worst though when and and
then and then at that moment right it's
when you realize yeah i bought a whole
pack at this point so i'm gonna i did it
i i i ate another one and i was like
they've changed it they've definitely
changed it i it's definitely not me i
asked my friend i was like listen did
you have the old one they were like yeah
and then i gave it to them and they were
like they were like okay try it try it
now try it like try this new one tell me
if it's changed they're like no it
doesn't take any different and my
women's last time you had it they were
like over a year ago i'm like you
wouldn't know then yeah you wouldn't
know because it's a slow gradual change
it's one year you wouldn't know so i
emailed the company
did you actually yeah because i wanted
the nerf they did it i wanted to know if
i was being crazy right
yeah you're definitely [ __ ] crazy
that's for sure who did you email
so
the email on the back of the packet yeah
so they so i found i found the company
online right and this is only because
i wouldn't have done this if my friend
didn't say no they didn't change it i
was like i was like they changed it and
they're like they didn't change it i'm
like they changed it
and so i found out the company it sounds
like a deleted scene from american
psycho yes like yeah this is so
unfathomable i understand this sounds
stupid yeah
it sounds like a always sunny episode
this i wanted but i really didn't
realize that the cheese is because i i i
goes to the [ __ ] factory and be like
tell me the truth
i know you're lying to me i wanted to
know because i wanted to know if i if my
taste buds have changed or if i was
being crazy or if you know i just needed
to know it was driving me insane okay
yeah so i emailed them right no response
and i was like what the [ __ ] so i call
up their customer service because i'm
like now i need to know because i didn't
reply right so i call them up and i ask
them and i'm like hey uh so this type of
dairylee dunker thing did you change the
recipe at any point in recent time and
they were like
hmm
can i get back to you and i was like
you're not going to get [ __ ] back to
it yeah sorry
oh this is like three years ago oh okay
this is like
yeah i gave them my number and they
actually called me back wow wow they
said no
and i was like what no no no no who
would have [ __ ] thought there's a
check i said check here check again
right
so then i was like what the [ __ ] i was
so annoyed man i thought [ __ ] like oh my
god like i [ __ ] it up man why am i an
idiot why did i think it changed yeah
a year later i got an email reply saying
that they had changed one of the like uh
one of the aspects of like the cheese or
something that they did and i was like i
felt vindicated bro i felt like you know
how like when you watch those movies
about someone being wrongly convicted
and caught and then they finally get out
i was i felt like that like i was like
thank you thank you guys i'm finally
free i finally solved the mystery that
they [ __ ] changed it i can't believe
they emailed you back yeah yeah thank
you
my god like
that employee must have really [ __ ]
cared you know i don't know why we care
about all our customers i'm not really
sure how that happened there it was
really bizarre somebody like [ __ ]
dusted off their inbox to be like
yeah remember that one guy you know you
met us last year if the ingredients
changed
but the fact they called me back just to
tell me no i was like that's weird
it's because you're probably the like
one
you're probably the one person to
actually [ __ ] go oh great customer
service you got it guys
i've never heard of a single person
actually phoning customer service for
like a food item and you call me a cat
well because no i was there wasn't a car
i was like i don't mean to know i was
like by the way um did you change the
recipe it doesn't matter how it doesn't
matter how strongly you say it what do
you mean the fact that you even [ __ ]
did it is like more telling than am i
not i i why am i not allowed to ask that
because it's who cares i care who
actually [ __ ]
that is given to children it is the
literal children's snack you are an
adult i wanted to know
i didn't ask rudely i just asked them
can i by the way just wondering did you
change the recipe
is that rude that's not rude
oh no man it's not about being rude it's
just like it's strange i understand it's
yeah it's very strange it's like there's
nothing the determination
what's wrong with that it took like 10
seconds to email them
but the fact that you also called them
up
yeah
i got to know how long did they put you
on hold how long was that no like how
long was that ringing it was interesting
because no one probably calls that knife
because no one's calling them who's
calling them
i can only imagine like the receptionist
to be like
that phone
oh they rings to blow the dust off
well because i think what inspired me to
do it is that on the uk there was a tv
show on channel 4 where they would they
would try and find out where
food items came from in the uk
so like if it was like canned tomatoes
and it would say like made in like
argentina or something yeah they would
just like go on this relentless triad to
go and like [ __ ] find out where it
was it was actually came from okay and
then they would go and visit the place
where it came right
i mean that's interesting yeah i think i
was inspired i was like i want to know
tell me
you know i i understand that it's not
i've never done it since but yeah
i don't think it's i don't think i was
being rude or anything i just asked them
if they changed it's not i'm not i'm not
criticizing you i feel like i've done
something badly here i'm being
criticized [ __ ] you guys i want to know
my one of my favorite challenges you're
not being criticized for being rude or
anything i'm just like
you were that bored
no it wasn't boredom it was
determination there's a difference i'm
just surprised you were that bored to be
that determined
no i mean i had other stuff to do
i just ignored it
clearly they weren't that important
are you telling me you've never
procrastinated in intriguing ways
on your work yes but i wish i wish i bet
i wish i could say like i could
procrastinate in intriguing ways no it's
never an interesting way if that is what
is the the benchmark for intriguing
you know in some weird way in my head to
justify my my procrastination i feel
like if i've done something that was on
my mind that i wanted to do it's almost
not procrastination in a way all right
like
when i'm supposed sometimes there are
some videos that i don't want to film
because i'm dreading the filming process
because it's quite a difficult video
yeah
i might struggle with it or i'm not too
i you know sometimes i'm not like 100 on
the video idea but i don't know until
it's edited right yeah so i kind of
dread it so sometimes i might just put
it off but sometimes it's like great
procrastination like doing my chores i'm
like i'm like this is this is
procrastination that is justified in my
head but i know what is it really no it
is but it is it is i should have done
that one thing but i'm just i'm i'm
lying to myself by doing tasks that i
need to do that i should that could
easily be be done any other time yeah
i'm just pushing forward now because i
don't want to do that one thing that is
procrastination that is because that's
the because it's not a destination but
it's still procrastinating i don't think
there's such a thing as efficient
procrastination
they're okay there's slightly more
efficient procrastination but at the
same time at the same time you have a
task that you need to do and you are
putting that task off right you can you
can you can you can lie to yourself and
say hey i'm doing something else
productive like cleaning which i do as
well but like i'm just like
sometimes there are videos that you need
to do asap right yeah you're just
putting them off because you don't want
to do it yeah right that's
procrastination regardless of what
you're doing to put it off you know you
could be doing cpr on someone and saving
their life you're still procrastinating
on that video bro let them let them die
bro do the video i'm kidding
you know that
if you are you know i would not have
chosen to clean that day the only reason
i chose to clean was because i didn't
want to do the [ __ ] video
i'm procrastinating on that video do you
ever do the cleaning where you don't
need to procrastinate uh no
so so basically you procrastinate on the
cleaning until you try to procrastinate
with something else and then you
procrastinate by cleaning yourself doing
those tasks that you've been putting off
when you really don't want to do
something oh yeah like i i just don't
lie to myself horrible i i just don't
lie to myself because i only clean when
i'm procrastinating on making videos
right and then the other day
the the other day um the other day i
just like cleaned my house about five
million times and i ran out of things to
procrastinate on so i made i made this
video called like jojo fans when they
figure out their bros don't suck dick
and that was made because i was
procrastinating on making videos and i'd
already cleaned the house
so like
it's really screaming at the bottom of
the barrel that is still procrastinating
yeah i know he's still procrastinating
that's what i'm saying you just said it
wasn't you said it wasn't no i'm saying
like there's no such thing ever like
every procrastination is made equal is
it procrastination if it's monetizable
yes
yes it's still procrastination okay i
was trying to help you man
i threw the rope and you threw it back
at me what the [ __ ]
no i'm i'm i'm arguing when you don't
want to film a video oh sorry are
getting going i'm arguing that all
procrastinally all procrastination is
made the same it's it's essentially
essentially you are putting something an
important that's what i argued and you
disagreed with me oh you said you said
that you can like min max
procrastination right there no no i said
you're still procrastinating even if
you're like cleaning that's still
procrastinating that's what i argue that
oh i thought you never said it was good
i thought you were just arguing the
opposite no okay why didn't you say that
at all i said listen to me god this is
why they trust his podcast his arguments
because god
you know i just wanted to disagree with
you [ __ ]
i literally said your point
i was like hold on for a second i had to
readjust you yeah i was like halfway
through that conversation i'm like you
just made the same point what the [ __ ]
you all about so i was just back to the
[ __ ] day already
like my mind was just like i can't
believe this is like uh the baby bells
do you have those in australia yeah i
[ __ ] love baby bears i miss those man
nothing beats cheese string we talked
about this nothing beats cheese strings
jesus thinks cheese strings on another
level but baby bell's next in line yeah
this is american i have baby back well
this talk of food is making me [ __ ]
starving i'm
salad starving enough for me earlier
today yeah yeah
all right i'm i'm actually starving
right now all this talk about food man
yeah [ __ ] the episode here's the page
uh we're about to have some [ __ ]
dearly dunkers right now uh old recipe
daily duncan apparently not because it's
[ __ ] even though it's the same recipe
no no no no we don't know that it was
two different companies so it could have
one of them said no one of them said yes
so
so we will never know
what's your favorite snacks growing up
have they changed over time i'm sure
you've had have you ever called them up
or emailed them i'm sure i've had a
local restaurant change on you as well
that is that is probably heartbreaking
yeah um i'm pretty sure i mean i feel
like i feel like being told century
isn't real every time i go to my local
restaurant and something's changed about
it you know get over it
it's called being an adult
do the patreon thing okay if you like to
support the show make sure to go to our
patreon patreon.com also follow us on
twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify and uh yeah
don't email companies about [ __ ]
children i think that's okay you can do
that if you're nice people like oh don't
do it if you have [ __ ] to do people
people email us and if they're polite i
don't care whatever you know what i
wonder like how did they find out that
for example with like the horse meat
thing in the uk
who figured that out something figured
out he eats a lot of horses yeah someone
who just loves horses
someone probably just smell it someone
probably just tested it
why why do you take people like this no
scientists always test stuff from
supermarkets do they do that yeah they
do you can't just not test the meat what
do you mean like how is it going to
check it's what they say it is well
clearly no one did for a while because
of the horse meat was in there well i
mean you know it's constantly [ __ ] i
mean you could you could do it one one
way change your supplier and then no one
checks well fair enough oh we're getting
something different anyway
we're hungry we're we're [ __ ] hungry
i'm [ __ ] hungry
[Music]
foreign